IT'S A LITTLE PAST THAT --
I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES WILL BE
JOINING US AS SOON AS THEY
CONCLUDE THEIR MEETING SO WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
THIS IS A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE EDUCATION GIVEN THE
SIZE OF THE CROWD OR NOT.
I'M SURE YOU ALL KNOW THAT
YOU'RE IN THE RIGHT SPOT.
WE'RE GOING TO COVER THREE
ISSUES TODAY.
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA IN THE STATE
WIDE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS SO.
WITH THAT THIS IS --
AGAIN AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
WITH THAT WHY DON'T WE GET
STARTED WITH --
ISSUE NUMBER ONE IT'S ITEM SIXTY
ONE HUNDRED DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT AND OUR FIRST PANEL.
IF YOU'LL JOIN US PLEASE
[inaudible]
THE COMMISSION.
GERMAN IF YOU WILL INTRODUCE
YOURSELVESFOR THE RECORD
STARTING TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT
SIR.
WARNINGS CHAIR MEMBERS ERIN AT
AREA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US MR
FREDDIE.
AND GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
KENNETH COUPON WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU MISTER CAPONE.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
MORNING I REALIZED I HAVE A
HANDOUT THAT I PASSED OUT LAST
WEEK THAT I WAS GOING TO
REFERENCE AGAIN TODAY BUT I DID
NOT BRING ANY MORE WITH ME.
SO I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT AND IF
NECESSARY WE CAN GET THAT OVER
TO YOUR STAFF --
AFTERWARD TODAY --
BUT WITH THAT --
GET TO MY MY COMMENTS SO TODAY
I'M GOING TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
AN OVERVIEW OF THE CALCULATION
OF THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
AND SOME OF THE THE CALCULATIONS
THAT GO I'VE GOT THE LEVELS FOR
EACH OF THE THREE YEARS IN THE
BUDGET WINDOW --
THAT WE HAVE UNDER THE PROPOSED
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF FUNDING EVER UNDER THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEED.
AT EIGHTY POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS UP FROM SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT NINE BILLION IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND FORTY
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS DURING THE
TROUGH OF THE RECESSION.
WITH CONTINUED REVENUE GROWTH
DURING THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION TOTAL
GENERAL FUND REVENUES AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
ARE ESTIMATED TO BE ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
FORTIN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AN
INCREASE OF FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN REVENUE LEVELS.
AT A TOTAL OF EIGHTY POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A PER
PUPIL EXPENDITURE FROM PROP
NINETY EIGHT OF JUST OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PUPIL AN
INCREASE OF ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS FOR PEOPLE
OVER. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVELS.
AS NOTED --
IN OFFICE USE.
THE FUNDING LEVELS --
420-171-81819 DECLINED --
COMPARED TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT.
LEVELS BY ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THAT WAS
LARGELY DUE TO LOWER THAN GROWTH
COMPARED TO THE BUDGET ACT AND A
YEAR OVER YEAR DECLINE IN
GENERAL FUND REVENUE GROWTH AS
WE WENT FROM. 201-718-21819 OUT
TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
THAT IN THE SECOND [inaudible]
BECAUSE WHILE.
THAT MAY SEEM A LITTLE BIT
COUNTER INTUITVE ESSENTIALLY
WELL GENERAL FUND REVENUES ARE
INCREASE ACROSS THE PERIOD
COMPARED TO BUDGET ACT THE YEAR
OVER YEAR REVENUE INCREASE OF
TWO POINT NINE BILLION AS HE
WENT.
TO SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN VERSES A
TWO AND A HALF BILLION DOLLAR
REVENUE INCREASES WE GO FROM.
SEVENTEEN TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
ACTUALLY HAS THE EFFECT
ESSENTIALLY OF LIMITING THE
GROWTH SOMEWHAT IN THE GUARANTEE
AS OPPOSED TO HAVE REVENUES HAD
GROWN BY LET'S SAY TWO POINT
NINE OR MORE IN IN BOTH YEARS
AND YOU HAD THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN GROWTH --
EQUALING OR OR ECLIPSING THE
GROWTH THAT SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
EXPERIENCE.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT ANY GROWTH IN
REVENUES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND BEYOND
APPROXIMATELY. TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED EXCUSE ME GROWTH BEYOND
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WOULD NOT
RESULT IN AN INCREASE OF THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE AS ESSENTIALLY
WOULD SWITCH US TO ATTEST TO
YEAR WHERE THE INFLATION
ADJUSTMENT.
THEN BECOMES A PER CAPITA
PERSONAL INCOME ADJUSTMENT AND
NOT A FUNCTION OF REVENUES.
RAINY DECREASING REVENUES IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHAT'S THE
PROB NINETY A ALSO LOSE ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE CENTS ON THE DOLLAR.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FURTHER EVER REVENUE INCREASES
BY OUR ESTIMATES OR DECREASES --
AT THE MAY REVISION WOULD IMPACT
THE GUARANTEE BY ABOUT FORTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR AS WE ARE
LOOKING TO PRETTY SOLIDLY BE IN
A TEST ONE YEAR.
BECAUSE THERE IS.
NO LONGER ANY OUTSTANDING MEAT
INSPECTOR BALANCE PROP NINETY
EIGHT WILL LIKELY NOT BE A
SENSITIVE TO INCREASES OR
DECREASES OR IN THIS CASE
PARTICULARLY INCREASES IN
GENERAL FUND REVENUES.
AS WE HAVE IN RECENT YEARS
OBSERVED AT THE MAY REVISION --
AND NOW THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
BUDGET LIKELY THE NON
PROPOSITION NINETY SIDE WILL
STAND TO GAIN PROPORTIONATELY
MORE FROM REVENUE INCREASES THAN
IN YEARS PAST BECAUSE OF THAT
MAINTENANCE FACTOR.
BEING FULLY PAID OFF NOW.
COM ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET
MAKES THE FINAL PAYMENT TOWARDS
OUTSTANDING SETTLE UP IN THIS
YEAR OTHER WAS STILL EXISTING SO
BALANCES --
TO PRIOR YEARS UNDER THE
GUARANTEE --
THAT FINAL PAYMENT IS
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS --
K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION
FORTUNATELY WILL NOT EXPERIENCE
A REDUCTION IN PRIOR KERN YOUR
APPROPRIATIONS SENSUALLY CASH
FLOW TO SCHOOLS --
DESPITE THOSE DECLINES IN THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE IN THE PRIOR
AND CURRENT YEAR THAT I
MENTIONED THAT'S BECAUSE OF TWO
SEPARATE MECHANISMS THAT WE'RE
USING WHERE ONE WHERE --
PROPOSING TO OVER PROBE
GUARANTEE BY ABOUT FORTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS THE WE DON'T
HAVE TO REDUCE IT AND IN THE
SECOND PIECE OF THAT AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN OR PROS IN THE
USE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OF SETTLE
UP. TO PAY FOR A PORTION OF LC
FIVE FUNDING IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WITH ALL THESE
ADJUSTMENTS AND MOVING PARTS ARE
JUST LAID OUT THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS STILL LEFT WITH
ABOUT TWO POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS AND AVAILABLE RESOURCES
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. TO SPEND
WITH OUR PROPOSAL AND MUSCLES
PROPOSALS AYE AYE COVERED --
IN OUR HEARING LAST WEEK SO I
WON'T GET INTO TO ME AT THE
CIVICS BUT OF COURSE HAPPY --
TO TO TALK LATER ABOUT THOSE TWO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE OF THE BOOK OF
THAT OF COURSE AS I MENTIONED
LAST WEEK IS TWO BILLION DOLLARS
GOING TOWARDS THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT OF THREE POINT 4%.
46% -- ON
THE CFF AND ALSO ABOUT A FIVE
HUNDRED SIX SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL A MADE UP OF
BOTH ONE TIME AND ONGOING MONEY
FOR SOME SPECIAL ED --
FUNDING AND THEN ALSO A THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS APPROXIMATELY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SOME VERY
VERY SUGGEST MEN'S --
WITHIN THEIR WORLD.
LASTLY I DO WANT TO MENTION OF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
REGARDING THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
CERTIFICATION PROCESS --
SPECIFICALLY THIS BUDGET
PROPOSES REPEALING THE COST
ALLOCATION SCHEDULE OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT TRIP MECHANISM THAT
WAS PASSED LAST YEAR AS PART OF
THE AB --
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE AND THEN
ALSO UP WE PROPOSED TO ELIMINATE
THE STATE'S ABILITY TO MAKE
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS THE
GUARANTEES FUNDED LEVEL IN THE
PRIOR YEAR --
OR INTENT WITH THIS IS HOPEFULLY
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT MORE CERTAINTY FOR SCHOOLS
WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR LEVELS OF
FUNDING IN THE PRIOR YEARS --
AND THEN ALSO GIVING --
THE MINISTRATION LITTLE BIT MORE
FLEXIBILITY BEING IN THE
GUARANTEE A WITHOUT I'LL
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS BUT HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS.
WELL WITH RESPECT TO THE CHANGE
IN THE CERTIFICATION PROCESS HOW
HOW IS THAT GOING TO IMPACT OUR
BUDGETING.
I REALIZE IT'S GOOD FOR THE LA
X..
AND THE AND THE AND FRANKLY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION IS YOU MAY.
RECALL FROM LAST WEEK --
YOU KNOW THEY THEY DON'T HAVE
THE THE CERTAINTY AND THEY'RE
ASKING FOR THE SAME THING
WHETHER IT'S IN THE FORM OF
RESERVE ACCOUNT OR SOME OTHER
BALANCING --
BALANCING TOOL BUT FROM A
BUDGETING STANDPOINT HOW HOW
DOES THIS REALLY WORK.
SURE SO --
FIRST WE CAN TALK ABOUT KIND OF
RETROSPECTIVELY SO FOR LOOKING
AT PRIOR YEARS AND NOT HAVING
THE COST ALLOCATION SCHEDULE
ANYMORE --
ESSENTIALLY WHAT LITTLE FUNCTION
HOW IT HAD FOR YEARS WHERE IN A
PRIOR YEAR WHERE --
THERE WERE ANOTHER WEEK'S
EXPERIENCE A DROP IN THE FOR
EXAMPLE IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE
HAD OVER A PRODUCTION --
THAT WE ARE NOW PROPOSING TO
OVER APPROPRIATE BY FORTY FOUR
MILLION.
ESSENTIALLY LOOKING FORWARD IN
THE FUTURE FUTURE YEARS IF WE
HAVE THAT SAME TYPE OF SITUATION
WE WOULD JUST HAVE THE DECISION
TO MAKE DO WE MAKE THAT --
REDUCE THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND
SOMEHOW CLAWED BACK THAT MONEY
POTENTIALLY WHICH HISTORICALLY
IT HAS BEEN VERY UNCOMMON OR DO
WE JUST OVER APPROPRIATE TO
GUARANTEE AND SENSUALLY GIVE
THAT CERTAINTY TO SCHOOLS THAT
THEY KNOW OKAY I'M NOT GOING TO
LOSE BACK ON THAT ON THAT.
CASH THAT ALREADY HAVE THAT'S
ALREADY GONE OUT --
NOT A LOT CHANGES THERE IT JUST
DOESN'T GIVE THE STATE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE --
TO COUNT THAT OVER PREPARATION
IN THIS CASE --
WITHIN THE COST ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE TO THEN BE ABLE TO USE
TOWARDS A OF A POTENTIAL FUTURE
SETTLE UP DEBT --
AND AS WE LOOK PRO SUBJECTIVELY --
IT DOESN'T CHANGE --
A WHOLE LOT ON ON THAT END
BECAUSE ESSENTIALLY --
WE ALREADY.
WOULDN'T BE FROM.
CALCULATING SETTLE UP FOR YOU
KNOW A BUDGET OR CURRENT YEAR
WE'D WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IT THAT'S
WITH THOUGHT THOSE ARE ALL.
RETROSPECTIVE CALCULATION SO AS
WE LOOK --
FORWARD PROSPECTIVELY --
THE PROPOSAL THAT I JUST.
MENTIONED DOESN'T REALLY IMPACT
OUR OUR PROSPECT OF BUDGETING --
THAT MUCH IT WE WE STILL WOULD
HAVE MOST OF THE SAME OPTIONS
THAT WE HAD UNDER --
THE THE PROPOSAL --
AND OF COURSE HISTORICALLY GOING
BACK AS WELL.
YOU KNOW I'M NEW TO THIS PROP
NINETY EIGHT DANCE BUT JUST TO
CUT THROUGH THAT.
WILL THERE EVER BE A TRUE UP IN --
THERE.
I 5% WHAT YOU'RE GETTING AT
CORRECTLY ARE THERE STILL WILL
BE A A TRUE UP SO WE'RE NOT
GETTING RID OF THE MORE SUBTLE
UP YOU CALL IT YES YES KNOW
PRECISELY SO THERE THERE WILL
STILL BE --
A MECHANISM WHEREBY WE WILL
ESTABLISH HOW MUCH SETTLE UP IS
IS GOING TO BE IS A CRUDE TO A
CERTAIN YEAR AND THEN OFFICE
SCHEDULED TO BE PAID OUT SO
THAT'S NOT CHANGING --
THAT THAT THAT WILL STILL EXIST --
THE IT'S KIND OF THE MORE COST
ALLOCATION SCHEDULE I MENTIONED
THAT WILL NOT EXIST AND THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS NEW --
WITH THE WITH WHAT WAS PASSED AT
THE BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR.
COLLEAGUES IN QUESTIONS.
EARLIER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I FIND
PROPOSITION NINETY TO BE IT
COMPLETELY CONFUSING.
SO I'M TRYING TO GET MYSELF UP
TO SPEED I HAD A QUESTION IT WAS
PASSED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
I APOLOGIZE IF YOU ALREADY
COVERED THIS BECAUSE THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT LATE.
WHY WAS PROP ONE ELEVEN AT IT
WHY WAS THERE A THIRD TEST ADDED?
RIGHT SO IF I CROSS RECALL
CORRECTLY --
PROP -- ONE
ELEVEN WAS LARGELY A RESULT OF I
FORGET EXACTLY WHICH I THINK IT
MIGHT HAVE BEEN --
NINETEEN NINETY THAT THERE WAS A
THERE WAS A RECESSION --
AND THAT AFFECT THE WHAT
HAPPENED WHERE YOU HAD A PROP --
EXCUSE ME TEST ONE WHICH IS
MEANT TO BE OF WHERE --
PROP NINETY EIGHT SHARES A OF
GENERAL FUND FISCALLY ABOUT 40%.
AND THEN TEST TO WHERE IT'S A
FUNCTION OF PER CAPITA PERSONAL
INCOME.
AND THOSE WERE THE THE ONLY TWO
POSSIBLE TAX BUT IT CAME TO BE
THAT IN A RECESSION SCENARIO --
THE GUARANTEE WAS ESSENTIALLY
OUTPACING ACTUAL GROWTH IN THE
ECONOMY IN THIS CASE A DECREASE
IN THE ECONOMY BUT WE HAD NO WAY.
TO WITHOUT SPENDING THE
GUARANTEE --
KIND OF ACCOUNT FOR THAT WITH
THE ECONOMY WAS DOING --
AND KIND OF TREAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT PROPORTIONALLY TEST THREE
WAS ADDED AND TO BE ABLE --
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT PER CAPITA
GENERAL FUND REVENUES AND THEN --
WITH THAT NOW BE ABLE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN THERE ARE YEARS
WHERE -- THE
ECONOMY IS IS --
DOING WELL BUT MAYBE GENERAL
FUND REVENUES ARE DOING AS WELL
SO THAT THE STATE'S NOT DOING AS
WELL A WEARABLE TO TAKE THAT
INTO ACCOUNT WHEN CALCULATING
GUARANTEE AND HAVE IT GROW OUT
OF PROPORTION THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
SUSTAINABLE GIVING WHAT'S
HAPPENING --
WITH WITH THE GUARANTEE THIS WAS
A WAY TO REDUCE PROP NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING AND RECESSION.
IT WAS IT WAS A WAY TO MAKE IT
ABLE TO GROW MORE --
PROPORTIONALLY WITH THE ECONOMY
LIKE I SAID.
LIKE TO LET THE LA ALSO.
THANK YOU BACKGROUND.
YES THANK YOU AT SOME DALY
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION CAN UPON
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
OF THE ORIGINAL VERSION OF
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AFFECTED
LEE CREATED A FIRE WALL AROUND
SCHOOL FUNDING--
BUT AS YOU KNOW SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY STATE BUDGET AND WE
ENTERED A RECESSION IT TURNED
OUT TO BE PRETTY DIFFICULT FOR
THE STATE TO BALANCE THE BUDGET
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO SCHOOL FUNDING.
OPPOSITION WHEN ELEVEN THAT
CREATED SOME NEW FORMULAS LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED BUT THERE
THE REAL THRUST OF THE MEASURE
WAS LEADING THE STATE PROVIDE
SCHOOLS A LITTLE BIT LESS DURING
TIGHT FISCAL TIMES.
IN EXCHANGE FOR GROWING SCHOOL
FUNDING BY QUICKLY WHEN THE
ECONOMY RECOVERED.
GREAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
SEVERAL QUESTIONS.
LA -- DID
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THE
BERMAN OF FINANCE PRESENTATION.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'LL
I'LL JUST KEEP MY REMARKS --
TO A LIMIT OF BACKGROUND AND IN
SOME COMMENT --
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT
THAT -- I I
SHARED EARLIER.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION GIVE
A PRETTY GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE
BIG MOVING PIECES AND THIS THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND I THINK THEIR PRESENTATION
WAS A TIMELY REMINDER THAT
YOU'VE GOT NEARLY A DOZEN INPUTS
THAT AFFECT THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
THE THREE MOST IMPORTANT I
GROWTH IN GENERAL FUND REVENUE
CHANGES IN STUDENT ATTENDANCE
AND CHANGES IN THE STATE ECONOMY.
AND EVERY YEAR THOSE FACTORS
TAKE ON KIND OF VARYING LEVELS
OF IMPORTANT SOMETIMES GROWTH IN
GENERAL FUND REVENUE IS MORE
IMPORTANT SOMETIMES THE CHANGES
IN STUDENT ATTENDANCE AND MORE
IMPORTANT.
A FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TURNING
TO PAGE.
ONE THE ADMINISTRATION SAY IS
THAT.
IN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT THE STATE THAT SCHOOL
FUNDING EQUAL TO TO ITS ESTIMATE
OF THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE AT THAT
TIME.
SINCE THEN WE'VE REVISED OUR
ESTIMATES OF THE NOW SCHOOL
FUNDING IS FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION ABOVE THE
GUARANTEE.
SO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO DO IS TO LET
SCHOOLS RETAIN ALL OF THAT MONEY
I DON'T TO CUTS DOWN TO
DEFERRALS.
ABOUT ON PAPER WE CLASSIFY IT AS
BEING A PAYMENT TOWARD SOME
PRIOR YEAR IS.
AND THAT'S A KIND OF SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE IT ONE AT LET'S TO AVOID
NY KIND OF IMMEDIATE YOUR TRUMP
DISRUPTION ON SCHOOL BUDGETS.
BUT IT ALSO ALLOWS THE STATE TO
BUILD ON NEXT YEAR'S MINIMUM
GUARANTEE ON THAT LOWER FACE
WHAT THE GUARANTEE ACTUALLY WAS
NOT THE HIGHER LEVEL OF FUNDING
SCHOOLS ACTUALLY RECEIVED.
AND SO IT'S KIND OF A
SIGNIFICANT DECISION FOR YOUR
OUT YOUR BUDGET CALCULATIONS.
TURNING TO PAGE TWO AS THE
ADMINISTRATION TOLD YOU THE
GUARANTEE IS GOING THREE POINT
6% IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND YOU PROBABLY RECOGNIZE THAT.
AS BEING A BIT LOWER THAN IN
SOME PREVIOUS YEAR IS --
A LOT OF THAT A PREVIOUS GROWTH
WAS FUELED BY THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT WE
CALL MAINTENANCE FACTOR THIS WAS
SOMETHING ADDED BY PROPOSITION --
ONE ELEVEN IT'S AND IT'S THAT
MECHANISM FOR LETTING THE STATE
AND PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT LESS
FOR SCHOOLS DURING TAKE TIME IS
AN EXCHANGE FOR GROWING FUNDING
WILL QUICKLY DURING GOOD TIMES --
THE STATE HAS NO OF PAID OFF ALL
OF THAT MAINTENANCE FACTOR AND
SO THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE.
RESULTING IN SCHOOL FUNDING
GOING AS QUICKLY AS IT HAS A SAY
OVER THE PAST FIVE OR SIX YEARS --
I THINK THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
PROBABLY GIVES YOU A GOOD FLAVOR
OF WHAT THAT GROWTH WILL LOOK
LIKE.
ASK FOR SOMETHING MORE IN THE
RANGE OF 324% PER YEAR RATHER
THAN FACE 6527% OF THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS --
THE ADMINISTRATION DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT PROPERTY TAX REVENUE BUT
IN THE PAST THAT SOME TIME HAS
BEEN AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE
DIFFERENT ESTIMATES --
BUT THIS YEAR ARE ESTIMATES OF
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE I
VERY VERY CLOSE.
AND THAT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
NEW OFTEN REDUCES --
HOW MUCH THE STATE HAS TO
PROVIDE FOR THE GENERAL FUND TO
MEET THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND STAR
ESTIMATES THIS YEAR ACROSS THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD A VERY CLOSE?
ONLY ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DIFFERENT --
PAGE THREE IS A SHOWING YOU.
WHAT THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GUARANTEE HAS MEANT FOR
PER PUPIL FUNDING SINCE
[inaudible]
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SO.
THIS IN NINETEEN TWENTY UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FUNDING
PER STUDENT WOULD BE TWELVE
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN DOLLARS.
THAT IS AN ALL TIME HIGH EVEN
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION --
BUT MIGHT NOT BE AS MUCH OF A
SURPRISE GIVEN THE LONG ECONOMIC
RECOVERY THAT WE'RE IN WE'RE
JUST THREE MONTHS NOW SHY OF THE
LONGEST ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN US
HISTORY.
AND THAT A STRONG GROWTH IN THE
ECONOMY STRONG GROWTH IN REVENUE
HAS PUSH THESE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FORMULAS AND PULLED
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE UP UPWARD
ALONG THAT SAME TRAJECTORY.
LOOKING UP BEYOND THE BUDGET
YEAR I MENTIONED ON THE TRAIN TO
PAGE FOUR I THINK I MENTIONED
SOME OF THESE THINGS ARE READY
BUT WE DID A FOR ABOUT. FOUR
YEAR LOOK AHEAD AT THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE UNDER TWO DIFFERENT
ECONOMIC SCENARIOS WE KNOW.
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS
VOLATILE IT CHANGES A LOT AND WE
WANTED TO GIVE KIND OF A A RANGE
OF WHAT YOU MIGHT EXPECT THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
SO WHEN I GROWTH SCENARIO THE
GUARANTEE WAS GROWING ROUGHLY IN
THE RANGE OF THREE POINT 4% PER
YEAR -- SEC --
UNDER ARREST THE RECESSION
SERIOUS NERIO WE MODELED WHICH
WAS REALLY MODELING KIND OF LIKE
WHAT A MODERATE RECESSION MIGHT
MEAN FOR THE BUDGET.
I THE GUARANTEE ENDS UP DROPPING
YEAR OVER YEAR SO UNDER THAT
SCENARIO IT DROPPED ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ANOTHER
BILLION IN.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SO THE
GROWTH SCENARIO YOU'VE GOT
ENOUGH MONEY TO COVER A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT PERHAPS A FEW
OTHER SMALLER PLANTATIONS.
AND RECESSION SCENARIO AT THE
GUARANTEE OFTEN TO A LEVEL WHERE
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
YOUR EXISTING SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
AND IN THE PAST THAT'S BEEN A
CONCERN FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
AND AND FOR SOME OF THE SCHOOL
GROUPS AS WELL --
SO IF YOU DID WANT TO AVOID SOME
THOSE REJECT MAKING SOME OF
THOSE REDUCTIONS IN THE FUTURE
WE THINK THAT'S PROBABLY A CASE
FOR BUILDING SOMEWHERE RESERVE
THIS.
EITHER IN YOUR STATE SCHOOL
RESERVE YOUR MAIN RAINY DAY FUND
ACCOUNT YOU'VE GOT DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR BUILDING DESERVES.
A RIGHT NOW THE STATE DOESN'T
HAVE ANY MONEY THAT SPECIFICALLY
SET ASIDE FOR SCHOOLS UNLIKE
SOME OF THE OTHER AREAS OF THE
BUDGET WE'VE CREATED RAINY DAY
ACCOUNTS JUST FOR THEM.
TURNING TO PAGE FIVE THIS IS
REALLY SHOWING KIND OF OUR
OUTLOOK FOR THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE THAT WE PUT TOGETHER
BACK IN NOVEMBER.
AND I THINK IT'S JUST.
A REMINDER OF HOW QUICKLY THE
PICTURE CAN CHANGE.
SO.
IF A RECESSION UNDER GROWTH
SCENARIO --
BY THE END OF THE FOUR YEAR
PERIOD THE GUARANTEE WOULD BE
NEARLY NINETY BILLION DOLLARS
UNDER A SESSION SCENARIO WOULD
BE MORE LIKE EIGHTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS SO YOU'VE GOT A
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR DIFFERENCE
IN JUST A FEW YEARS BETWEEN.
A GOOD ECONOMIC SCENARIO IN A
PORT.
ONE TURNING TO PAGE SIX THIS IS
LARGELY JUSTER RECAP OF ALL OF
THE PROPOSALS OF THE GOVERNOR
HAS THIS YEAR I WON'T COVER ANY
OF THESE IN DETAIL NOW YOU PUT
ABOUT THE LAST WEEK AND YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT THEM AND FUTURE
HEARING THIS --
I THINK AT COMPARED WITH
PREVIOUS YEARS THIS IS REALLY
ONE OF THE MOST STRAIGHTFORWARD
BUDGETS YOU'RE EVER LIKELY TO
SEE HOW THE GOVERNOR'S PUTTING
NEARLY ALL OF THE AVAILABLE
FUNDING --
TOWARDS COVERING COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT AND JUST ONE OR TWO
OTHER AUGMENTATIONS IN THE CAPE
OF AREA.
TURN TO PAGE SEVEN I THINK MAYBE
THE MOST NOTABLE DIFFERENCE FROM
PREVIOUS YEAR IS.
IS THE MIX OF ONE TIME AN ON
GOING FUNDING --
HISTORICALLY. FOR THE PAST SIXTY
SET ASIDE SOME FUNDING IN THE
GUARANTEE EACH YEAR FOR ONE TIME
ACTIVITY IS.
AT THAT'S AVERAGE PARADE A LOT
BUT IT'S AVERAGE ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR.
AND THAT APPOACH HAS KIND OF
BEEN AN INTENTIONAL CHOICE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE
TIME FUNDING BUILT INTO THE
BUDGET YOU'RE GIVING YOURSELF A
LITTLE BIT OF A CUSHION AGAINST
FUTURE VOLATILITY IN THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
IF THE GUARANTEE DROPS NEXT YEAR
YOU CAN JUST LET THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING EXPIRE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
MAKE CHANGES TO ONGOING PROGRAMS
ARE THINGS THAT SCHOOLS ARE
GOING TO FIND MORE DISRUPTIVE.
THIS YEAR --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
VERY LITTLE IN ONE TIME FUNDING --
IN NINETEEN TWENTY JUST THREE
MILLION OF HIS NINETEEN TWENTY
SPENDING LEVELS FOR ONE TIME
ACTIVITY IS --
ON TOP OF THAT THIS BUDGET ALSO
PROPOSES USING SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION IN ONE TIME FUNDS TO PAY
FOR SOME ONGOING PROGRAM COSTS.
AND THAT SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
THIS IS A ONE TIME FUNDS TO PAY
FOR ONGOING ACTIVITIES BUILD IN
A LITTLE BIT OF A SHORTFALL NEXT
YEAR IT'S SOMETHING YOU HAVE
IT'S KIND OF THE FIRST CALL IN
YOUR DOLLAR. FOR NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET.
AND IT COULD MAKE THINGS.
REDUCES THE FOR INCREASES THAT
SCHOOLS MIGHT EXPECT MIGHT
RECEIVE THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
AND SO THIS IS A LITTLE OF A
RISKIER APPROACH COMPARED TO
SOME PREVIOUS BUDGET SEN --
PROBABLY WHAT WE THINK OF AS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN TERMS
OF THE WAY THE WHOLE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGES STRUCTURED.
US ARE TURNING TO PAGE.
EIGHT I'LL JUST HAVE TO LITTLE
BIT AM FROM KIND OF THE WAY WE
WERE IN JANUARY TWO WHERE HOW
THINGS MIGHT INVOLVE COME MAY.
AND ON BALANCE WE THINK THAT
THERE'S A BIT MORE DOWNSIDE IS
AN UPSIDE AS FAR AS POSSIBLE
CHANGES IN THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT BUDGET.
A PART OF THAT STORY HAS TO DO
WITH REVENUE.
OF THE STOCK MARKET DROPPING
NOTABLY AT THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AT AFTER THE
ADMINISTRATIONOF LOCKED DOWN
ITS ECONOMIC ASSUMPTIONS.
IT'S MADE UP A LOT OF GROUND
SINCE THEN BUT WE STILL THINK
THERE COULD BE --
LOWER REVENUE AND INTO THE
CURRENT YEAR COMPARED TO THE
JANUARY ESTIMATES.
AND WE'VE ALSO SEEN SOME SIGNS
THAT THE ECONOMY MIGHT BE
SLOWING JUST ATTACH --
INCLUDING A SMALL UPTICK IN
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS AND A SMALL
DOWN TAKE AND HOME SALES.
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS
YOU HEARD EARLIER THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE IS SENSITIVE TO
CHANGES IN REVENUE. FOR EACH
DOLLAR OF LOWER REVENUE WILL
DROP ABOUT FIFTY FIVE CENTS IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FORTY
SOMETHING DOLLARS IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY AT THE OTHER
PART OF THE STORY IS FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO EXCLUDE
SOME COSTS THAT WE THINK --
ARE VERY LIKELY TO MATERIALIZE
IN THE COMING.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS A ONE TIME
PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL IN SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY I RELATED TO
KIND OF AN INCORRECT ALLOCATION
THAT OCCURRED IN THE COUNTY
PREVIOUSLY.
WE ALSO THINK THAT SOME OF YOUR
FORMULA DRIVEN SPENDING IS GOING
TO BE HIGHER THAN.
WHAT SYSTEM IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET?
THAT INCLUDES --
SOME COSTS FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION COMMUNITY COLLEGE A
QUESTION.
AND YOUR ATTENDANCE DRIVEN COSTS
FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
AND SO BETWEEN THE LOWER
GUARANTEE AND HIGHER COSTS WE
THINK YOU MIGHT BE LOOKING AT
KIND OF A COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION
IN ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT WOULD
MAKE YOUR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BUDGET.
A TIGER BY THE TIME OF THE MAY
REVISION.
A TURNING TO PAGE NINE AS FAR AS
KIND OF PREPARING FOR THAT AND
HOW YOU MIGHT RESPOND --
I THINK THE NEXT.
COUPLE HEARINGS WILL GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO THINK THROUGH ALL OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS.
BUT WHEN I THINK ABOUT.
WHAT YOU'RE HIGHEST PRIORITIES
ARE THINGS YOU MIGHT BE WILLING
TO REJECT OR REDUCE IF THE
BUDGET IS TIGHTER SENT THAT
MIGHT BE THE DECISION YOU'RE
FACING IN MAY?
YOU MIGHT ALSO THINK ABOUT
BUILDING A BIT LITTLE BIT MORE
OF A BUDGET QUESTION BY
REPLACING SOME OF THE GOVERNOR
IS A PROPOSED ONGOING SPENDING
WITH ONE TIME INITIATIVE THIS.
JUST MUCH EASIER TO KIND OF PULL
BACK ON THE ONE TIME THEN THE ON
GOING IF THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED TO
DO THE BALANCE THE BUDGET AND
MAY.
A SO FINALLY TRYING TO PAGE TEN
I'LL TALK JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE TRIP PROCESS
[inaudible]
AND THIS IS AS THE
ADMINISTRATION TOLD YOU REALLY
ABOUT THE WAY THE STATE
ADDRESSES THE GUARANTEE AFTER
THE YEAR IS OVER THIS IS KIND OF
A UNIQUE FEATURE OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUDGET.
AND ALMOST ALL OTHER PARTS OF
YOUR BUDGET YOU'RE NOT MAKING
CHANGES ONCE THE FISCAL YEAR IS
OVER.
BUT THESE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FORMULAS CONTINUE TO
CHANGE.
AS AS LONG AS NINE MONTHS AFTER
THE YEAR IS OVER AND SOMETIMES
EVEN LONGER THAN THAT
[inaudible]
AT TRADITIONALLY.
THOSE CHANGES ARE IN THE RANGE
OF SAY TENS OF MILLIONS TO A FEW
HUNDREDS MILLION HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS --
SO THEY CAN BE SIGNIFICANT
PARTICULARLY IF YOU'RE IN A
TIGHTER AND TIGHTER BUDGET
SITUATION.
USUALLY WHEN THE GUARANTEE IS
HIGHER THAN WHAT THE STATE
ESTIMATED PREVIOUSLY ARE THE
STATE MAKES THE ONE TIME PAYMENT
TO WHAT WE CALL SETTLE UP TO
THAT HIGHER FUNDING LEVEL.
WHEN THEY GET YOUR IN TEA IS
LOWER THAN THE STATE ESTIMATED
PREVIOUSLY WHAT WE USUALLY DO IS
TAKE THAT FUNDING ABOUT THE
GUARANTEE AND WE CLASSIFY IT TO
BECOME IT TOWARD THE PRIOR YEAR
OR SOME OTHER YEAR WE HAVEN'T
ALREADY MET THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE?
AT THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING.
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND IT'S
OUT WE DO IT BECAUSE WE WANT
SCHOOLS TO KEEP THE CASH THEY'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED BUT WE DON'T
WANT THAT HIGHER FUNDING TO BE
THE BASE FOR CALCULATING NEXT
YEAR SCHOOL FUNDING APPLICATION
[inaudible]
AT THE GOVERNOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET PACKAGE
ESSENTIALLY PROPOSED AUTOMATING
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS.
DIRECTLY WE HAD DONE THEM COME
ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS TO
TRAILER LEGISLATION LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PACKAGE WOULD HAVE JUST
DIRECTED THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DO THM.
AND IT AUTOMATICALLY UNLESS THE
LEGISLATURE MADE A DIFFERENT
DECISION.
AND THAT WAS DESIGNED TO MAKE
CHANGES IN THE GUARANTEE A
LITTLE BIT LESS DISRUPTIVE FOR
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS THE REST OF
THE STATE BUDGET.
AFTER TURNING TO PAGE ELEVEN THE
PROPOSAL'S ESSENTIALLY.
AS KIND OF TWO INTERRELATED
PROPOSALS.
OUT ONE IS TO NOT DO THE
AUTOMATIC AND THE OTHER IS TO
PROHIBIT THE STATE FROM MAKING
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS TO SCHOOL
FUNDING IN THE PRIOR YEAR WHILE
STILL REQUIRING OPERATE JUST
MEANT.
AND I THINK IN ANALYZING THIS
PROPOSAL WE IDENTIFIED SOME OF
THE SAME CONCERNS THAT YOU REYES
MISTER CHAIR.
WHICH HAD TO DO WITH KIND OF
WHAT THAT MEANS FOR THE REST OF
YOUR STATE BUDGET.
IF YOU WERE TO ADOPT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSALS WE
THINK YOU WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE
COMMITTING TO HAVING ANY DROPS
IN STATE REVENUE FALL ON THE
ENTIRELY ON THE NONPROFIT THIS
NINETY EIGHT SIDE OF YOUR BUDGET.
AND THAT'S GONNA MAKE YOUR
OVERALL BUDGET BALLENGER
BALANCING TASK LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT --
BOTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
POTENTIALLY IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
TO AND SO WHAT WE RECOMMEND IS
THAT YOU REJECT BOTH OF THOSE
PROPOSALS AND MAINTAIN --
THE THE NEW PROCEDURES YOU PUT
IN PLACE LAST YEAR WE THINK
THOSE WERE OUT A CLEAR STEP
FORWARD AND I GIVE THOSE LITTLE
THE CHANCE.
TO WORK AT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THEM.
SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
WERE YOU MENTION THIS.
A STATE SCHOOL RESERVE
ACCOUNTANT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
CONCEPT WE DO HAVE THAT CONCEPT
UNDER WHAT PROP [inaudible] TWO
BUT TO THE CONDITIONS FOR
MANDATORY FUNDING OF THE RESERVE
ACCOUNT HAVE NOT OCCURRED.
GIVEN THAT WHAT WHAT MECHANISM
WOULD WE USED TO TO FUND THE
STATE RESERVE ACCOUNT AYE THE
FOREIGN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
ASSUME --
COULD THAT BE USED TO FUND THE
STATE RESERVE ACCOUNT I REALIZED
AMBIENT THERE WOULD BE AN IMPACT
POTENTIALLY ON ON THE LA A IS.
YEAH IF YOU WERE TO USE THE FORD
IN SEVENTY FIVE MILLION YOU HAVE
TO MAKE SOME KIND OF REAL
REDUCTION TO SCHOOLS NOT GIVE
THEM AS MUCH CASH AS THEY WERE
ANTICIPATING.
SINCE THE YEAR IS ALREADY
STARTED THEY MIGHT FIND THAT A
LITTLE BIT MORE DISRUPTIVE BUT
YOU COULD TAKE SOME OF THE MONEY
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING
FOR NEW PROPOSALS THIS YEAR.
LIKE SAY THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROPOSAL OR SOME OTHER PROPOSAL
YOU WEREN'T INTERESTED IN
FUNDING AND USE THAT TO MAKE --
TO MAKE A DEPOSIT IN THIS IN A
RESERVE.
AND YOU COULD DO THAT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS YOU COULD MAKE AN
OPTIONAL DEPOSIT IN THE STATE
SCHOOL RESERVE THE SAME WAY
YOU'VE MADE OPTIONAL DEPOSITS IN
THE REGULAR STATE RESERVE.
IF YOU DON'T THINK THE FORMULAS
FOR THE STATE SCHOOL RESERVE I
QUITE RATES YOU COULD.
CREATE A NEW STATE RESERVE THAT
WOULD BE JUST FOR SCHOOLS.
YOUCOULD ALSO THINK ABOUT IF
YOU ARE WILLING TO USE SOME OF
THE STATE'S MAN RESERVE TO FUND
SCHOOLS SO YOU'VE GOT A LOT OF
OPTIONS THERE AND WE CAN HELP
YOU AND IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THAT HELP YOU KIND OF THINK
THROUGH THE TRADE OFFS OF THOSE
DIFFERENT.
OPTIONS WELL I'M SO HAVING NO
HEARD.
YOU KNOW THIS.
NOW FOR TWO HEARINGS.
AND BEFORE I AM SOMEWHAT
SENSITIVE TO THE BUDGETING
ISSUES IN THE EDUCATION FIELD
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO BUDGET FOR
PROGRAMS AND YOUR THERE'S
REVENUE UNCERTAINTY.
WHETHER IT'S CASE YOU FOURTEEN
OR A HIGHER HIGHER ED.
AND HOW YOU LEVEL THAT OUT GIVEN
THE VOLATILITY OF OUR STATE
REVENUE STREAM.
AND THE WAY WE BUDGET --
YEAR BY YEAR EVEN IF WE TAKE A
MULTI YEAR LOOK AND LOOK BACK.
AND THERE HAS TO BE A WAY TO
STRUCTURE SOME SORT OF A RESERVE
SYSTEM OR CUSHION.
WHERE WE CAN --
DID TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
VOLATILITY OF THE REVENUE.
YET ALLOWS THE SCHOOL WHETHER
IT'S A K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT OR LET OR DISTRICT OR
LAST WEEK WEEKS HIGHER EDUCATION
FOLKS.
THE FLEXIBILITY TO PLAN PROGRAMS
HIGHER FACULTY.
ARE TEACHERS STEP WHICH PROGRAMS
AND NOT HAVE TO DEAL WITH A MID
COURSE CORRECTION
NOW I REALIZE THAT'S WHAT THE
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION IS TO ALLOW THEM TO DO
THAT BUT THERE'S GOT TO BE A
BETTER WAY. TO TO DO THAT IN OUR
CALIFORNIA BUDGETING SYSTEM AND
THAT'S THAT'S THE BASIS FOR MY
FOR MY QUESTION FINANCIAL ME
WILL WILL BE AS ONE MORE AND
THEN WILL BE TURNED OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION.
THE REUSING FOR ONGOING PROGRAMS
INSTEAD OF ONE TIME SPENDING.
I ASSUME YOU'RE PROJECTING
[inaudible]
CONTINUED GROWTH.
AS OPPOSED TO THE RECESSION
SCENARIO.
YES YEAH WE ARE OUR CURRENT
ESTIMATES DON'T DON'T TAKE INTO
TO ACCOUNT A RECESSION CENERI SO
WE ARE.
ESTIMATING CONTINUED GROWTH SO
WITH CONTINUED GROWTH IN THE THE
THE PROGRAMS.
THAT'S GOING TOWARD WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY CONTINUE ASSUMING
THAT GROWTH SCENARIO IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR YES THAT IS THE INTO.
TELL YOU ANY QUESTIONS DELIVER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I THINK
MY QUESTION IS ALONG THE SAME
LINES AS YOURS I AM WORRIED
ABOUT.
HOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS
PLAN --
GIVEN THE FLUCTUATING.
THE THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THEY GET
FROM PROP NINETY EIGHT MY
QUESTION IS.
DO WE THINK THE AVERAGE OUR
DAILY GUARANTEE IS THE BEST WAY
TO FIND.
SCHOOLS BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
THAT IT'S THIRTY FAULT OF THE
SCHOOL IF THERE ARE NOT THAT
STUDENT ENROLLMENT IS DOWN BUT
YOU HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT OF
TEACHERS YOU HAVE THE SAME.
FACILITIES THAT YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT.
IS THAT THE BEST WAY TO FIND OUR
SCHOOLS.
I WOULD SAY THAT --
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS A POSITION ON
IT AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE IS
IS THE BEST WAY OR NOT BUT THAT
WAS WHAT WAS INCLUDE NINETY
EIGHT AND YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE
MEASURE THAT --
THE VOTERS APPROVED --
I THINK WE CAN PROBABLY GET INTO
ALL OF MUCH LESS CONVERSATION
ABOUT MAYBE IF IT'S APPROPRIATE
OR OR NOT --
BUT LIKE I SAID I DON'T THINK
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A HAS A A
POSITION CERTAINLY THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS.
YOU KNOW THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED BUT FAIR ENOUGH LA A
WHAT DO YOU THINK.
AB USING AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE IS A LITTLE IS
SIMILAR TO THE WAY YOU BUDGET
OTHER PROGRAMS MOST OTHER
PROGRAMS IN THE BUDGET HAVE SOME
KIND OF CASE LOAD ADJUSTMENT
WHETHER THAT SLOT SORTER NUMBER
OF PATIENTS SERVED AND HEALTH
CARE CONTEXT.
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE A SORT OF THE
CASELOAD MEASURE WE'VE PICKED
FOR OUR PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IN SCHOOL FUNDING --
HAVING SOME KIND OF A YOU KNOW A
KID A CASELOAD MEASURE I THINK
MAKES SENSE --
I THINK WHAT'S KIND OF DIFFERENT
FOR SCHOOLS NOW IS IN THE PAST
THAT ADJUSTMENT IS ALWAYS BEEN
VERY POSITIVE SCHOOL ATTENDANCE
IS GOING 223%.
IN THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS THAN
IT WAS FLAT.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IT
STARTED DECLINING.
AND THAT'S REALLY A NEW ERA FOR
SCHOOL THE NUMBER WE HAVEN'T HAD
A SUSTAINED DECLINE IN STUDENT
ATTENDANCE FOR A COUPLE DECADES
NOW BUT THAT IS KIND OF THE
REALITY SCHOOLS ARE LOOKING AT
BOTH FOR THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
AND EVEN BEYOND THAT.
OKAY I I WOULD CHALLENGE ALL OF
US TO MAYBE THINK OF THINGS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY THANK YOU.
A QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES
[inaudible] ZERO IS PICKING
BEGAN OFFER CENTER LABELS
QUESTION ---HOW MANY YEARS IN THE FUTURE DO
YOU THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE?
SOME THE DECLINING --
IN ROMANS --
GIVEN.
WHAT OUR DEMOGRAPHICS FOLKS ARE
SAYING I THINK IT'S VERY SIMILAR
TO WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS IS OBSERVING
AS WELL?
AS USE ME LIKE CAN MENTIONED --
STARTING IN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
WE'VE BEEN SEEING THIS DECLINE
NOW KIND OF COMING OUT AS WE
CONTINUE RECOVER FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION AND WHAT WE ARE --
SEEING THAT THAT IS LARGELY A
FUNCTION OF IS --
THE BIRTH RATES ARE DECLINING
SOLD MORE AND MORE --
AND LIFE AND THEREFORE THERE'S
JUST FEWER CHILDREN TO
MATRICULATED UP THROUGH THE CELL
THIS COULD GO ON FOR DECADES AND
YOU'RE SAYING.
RIGHT I ATTENTION WE SOLD
BECAUSE IT'S BASED PRIMARILY ON
BIRTH RATES WE WERE PRETTY
CONFIDENT AT LEAST FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS BECAUSE EVEN IF PRESS
INCREASED.
TODAY YOU'VE GOT FIVE MORE YEARS
BEFORE THOSE THAT LARGER COHORT
ENTERS THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
I PROJECTIONS I THINK GO OUT.
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF
FIFTEEN TWENTY TO TWENTY YEARS
AND WE DO HAVE DECLINES.
MODEST DECLINES OVER THAT ENTIRE
PERIOD OKAY LET ME COUPLE OF THE
QUESTIONS.
TO OF FOR EITHER ONE A VIEW --
I WATER WHAT'S THE A SPENDING
PER PUPIL AND CLASS SIZES AND
THEN I HAVE A COUPLE OF THE
QUESTIONS AFTER THAT BUT
SPENDING FOR PEOPLE OF PEOPLE ON
THE AVERAGE CLASS SIZE.
AND HOW DOES IT COMPARE. TO
OTHER STATES AND OTHER WERE SORT
OF CALIFORNIA RANK AMONG.
SURE SO I CAN I CAN TAKE THAT
QUESTION SO PER PUPIL FUNDING
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
INTO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
PUPIL IN NINETEEN TWENTY THAT'S
AS HIGH AS IT'S EVER BEEN
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION.
AS FAR AS CLASS SIZE --
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHT NOW THE RATIO
OF TEACHERS TO STUDENTS ABOUT --
TWENTY ONE THAT'S NOT KIND OF
AVERAGE CLASS SIZE THAT'S JUST
TOTAL NUMBER OF FULL TIME STAFF
DIVIDED BY NUMBER OF STUDENTS --
WHICH IS KIND OF IN LINE WITH
THE HISTORICAL AVERAGE IT WAS
ABOUT --
TWENTY ONE PRIOR TO THE GREAT
RECESSION GREW QUITE A BIT
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION AND
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS IT'S BEEN
DROPPING BACK MORE TO THAT
HISTORICAL.
LEVEL I COMPARED TO SOME OTHER
STATES THAT'S WERE HIGH WE
TYPICALLY RANK A PRETTY LOW IN
TERMS OF THE RATIO OF A STUDENTS
TO TEACHERS.
I MEAN THAT'S KIND OF FOR MANY
YEARS THAT WE'VE TENDED TO HAVE.
ABOVE AVERAGE CLASS SIZE.
OKAY IN IN --
COUPLE OTHER COMBINED QUESTIONS
IN RANKING FOR CALIFORNIA RANKS
ON STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND
TEACHER SALARIES.
A TWENTY TWO SALARIES IT'S
ACTUALLY JUST THE REVERSE WE'VE
TEND TO RANK AMONG THE TOP FIVE
STATES FOR TEACHER SALARIES.
COM TO JUST TOTAL BUT I VIçT
TOTAL SPENDING ON TEACHER
COMPENSATION SO --
BASE SALARY WAS JUST OVER EIGHTY
THOUSAND FOR THE AVERAGE TEACHER
AND IN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN A PLUS
ANOTHER THIRTEEN THOUSAND ON
AVERAGE AND HEALTH BENEFITS --
SO THAT --
THOSE NUMBERS BUT CALIFORNIA I'M
IN THE TOP IN THE RANKINGS FOR
TEACHER SALARY.
ON STUDENT PERFORMANCE WHAT
WE'VE GENERALLY BEEN RANKED LOW --
IF YOU LOOK AT SORT OF NATIONAL
ASSESSMENTS LIKE I NEED THIS
ASSESSMENT OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ADMINISTERS.
AYE WE'VE WE'VE BEEN LOW ON THAT
ASSESSMENT AND HAVE BEEN FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
LET ME OF FOLLOW UP ON THAT IF I
MIGHT.
HAVE THERE BEEN STUDIES YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPARISONS
STATE TO STATE AND I STARTED TO
SEE THEM SINCE I RECEIVE THIS
NEW ASSIGNMENT [inaudible]
OF SIXTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT IN WHEREVER WASHINGTON
OR SOME PLACE AND YOU SEE HERE
ON THE EAST COAST.
RESIST TWELVE THOUSAND HERE HAVE
THERE BEEN ANY STUDIES TOASSESS
WITHIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
AND STATES.
RATIOS OF ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSE
VERSUS --
TEACHER CLASSROOM --
EXPENSE IN TERMS OF SALARIES AND
NUMBERS [inaudible]
JENNIFER QUESTION.
I I I THINK SO REAL CLEAR
QUESTION LET ME SEE ME AS GET
THAT WELL LET ME START WITH THE
BACKGROUND AND THEN I CAN
ELABORATE.
WE'VE YES WE DO COLLECTED SCHOOL
ACCOUNTING DATA FROM ALL
DISTRICTS AND OFFICES LIKE OURS
AND I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
ANALYZE THAT.
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SPEND A FAIRLY
SMALL SHARE OF THE BUDGET
ACTUALLY ON KIND OF
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD THAT'S
ONLY TEN OR 11%.
IF YOU COUNT ALL EXPENDITURES ON
SAY THEY'RE AUDITOR'S ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD AND SUPERINTENDENT
AND ALL THIS SORT OF CENTRAL
OFFICE STAFF --
IT'S NOT VERY HIGH.
IF DISTRICTS SPEND REALLY ABOUT
TWO THIRDS OF THEIR BUDGET ON
INSTRUCTION THE NEXT LARGEST
COMPONENT IS FACILITY IS --
SO ADMINISTRATIVE EXPENSES JUST
AS A KIND OF A SHARE OF ALL
SPENDING AREN'T A BIG CHUNK OF
MOST DISTRICTS BUDGETS.
SO THEN IT IS A QUESTION OF HOW
TO FIND OUT HOW TO FIND A WAY TO
GET MORE MONEY INTO THE
CLASSROOM IF IN FACT TWO THIRDS
OF THE DISTRICT BUDGETS ARE
GOING TO DIRECT INSTRUCTIONAL --
EFFORTS.
RIGHT.
IN THE STATE.
I'M NOT SURE I HAVE ANY SORT OF
I MEAN IF THERE'S AYE A GREAT IF
THE I DON'T KNOW OF ANY STUDIES
THAT HAVE TRIED TO STAY WELL
COULD WE TAKE HOW MUCH WORSE
SPENDING ON ADMINISTRATION NOW
AND KIND OF SHIFT EVEN MORE OF
THAT -- TO
THE CLASSROOM THE STATE'S TRIED
TO DO SOME THINGS LIKE THAT IN
THE PAST I WITH.
SAY CAPS ON STUDENT TEACHER
RATIOS AND REQUIRING MINIMUM
SHARES OF THE BUDGET TO GO
TOWARDS INSTRUCTION --
I DON'T KNOW OF ANY EVALUATIONS
OF LOOKED AT WHETHER THOSE HAVE.
ARE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
RELATIVELY LOW SHERIFF THAT
SOMETHING THAT DISTRICT WITH ON
THEIR OWN.
WELL SO YOU KNOW SOME OF US ARE
JUST FRUSTRATED AS TO HOW WE HOW
WE DO MORE. FOR A VERY VERY
IMPORTANT AREA.
OF OUR STATE OPERATION AND
THAT'S OF EDUCATION AND IN
PARTICULAR TEACHING STUDENTS IN
THAT CASE THROUGH TWELVE IN CASE
YOU FOURTEEN SYSTEM AND HOW DO
WE GET MORE MONEY.
INTO INTO WHEREVER THE CLASSROOM
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
AND THE BUDGET IS LIMITED EVEN
THOUGH IT'S FAIRLY STAGGERING --
AND LOOKING AT OPTIONS AND WE'RE
TO FIND MONEY TO PUT MORE MONEY
WHERE THE MONEY IS NEEDED AND
THAT IS IN THE CLASSROOM --
VISIT HIGH COST STATE SO
TEACHERS OF WE MAY BE HIGH ON
THE LIST IN TERMS OF TEACHERS'
SALARY AND BENEFITS BUT IT ALSO
COSTS A LOT OF MONEY TO LIVE
HERE AND WE CERTAINLY WANT.
HIGH QUALITY TEACHERS LIVING
HERE AND TEACH THAT'S THE
GENESIS OF MY QUESTION AND IT
PROBABLY WASN'T AS CLEAR AS IT
SHOULD BE SO.
STAY TUNED GIVE ME A FEW MORE
WEEKS HERE AND I MAY GET BETTER
AT THAT.
QUICK COLLEAGUES ANY FOR THE
QUESTION ELEVEN ONE QUICK FOLLOW
UP WHEN YOU SEE 10211% ON
OVERHEAD WHAT FALLS AND OVERHEAD.
BUT WE COULD GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC
LESS BUT IT'S THINGS LIKE THE
EXPENSES OF THE SCHOOL BOARD THE
SUPERINTENDENT OR
SUPERINTENDENT'S DEPUTY IS FOR
THE CENTRAL OFFICE EXPENSES SO
NOT THE SCHOOL SITE PRINCIPAL OR
AND THIS.
EXPENSES AT THE SCHOOL SITE.
COULD BE THINGS LIKE --
LIKE SAY THE CONTRACT FOR THE
AUDITOR'S OR FOR FOR LEGAL
ASSISTANCE KIND OF ALL THINGS
LIKE THAT AND I THAT PERCENTAGE
DOES FLUCTUATE SO WE CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH YOUR STAFF ON THE
SPECIFIC AMOUNT.
FOR THAT'S OKAY I WAS JUST
CURIOUS WHAT FALLS UNDER THAT
BECAUSE YOU SAID 10211% IS
RATHER LOW SO DOES THAT MEAN
THAT SUPERINTENDENTS.
UP INTO THE CITY CALIFORNIA
THEIR SALARIES ARE WITHIN RANGE.
OF WHAT OTHER STATES ARE PAYING.
I DON'T KNOW OF ANYONE WHO
COMPILES DATA ON CONSUMER
INTENDANTS ALREADY WE HAVE IT
MORE FOR THE TEACHERS IDE.
I THINK IT'S MORE OF A A
FUNCTION.
OF JUST NOT HAVING ALL THAT MANY
OF THOSE PEOPLE IN A DISTRICT IF
YOU LOOK AT KIND OF WHO THE
PEOPLE ARE WHO MAKE UP A
DISTRICT STAFF.
WHAT OVERWHELMINGLY TEACHERS AND --
KIND OF SUPPORT STAFF
SECRETARIES BUS DRIVERS CLERICAL
WORKERS --
THAT THE CENTRAL OFFICE STAFF
JUST AREN'T A VERY BIG HERE OF
ALL THE STAFF THAT INTO DISTRICT
BUCKLEY EMPLOYS GOTCHA I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS I'VE BEEN MADE
AWARE OF A A COUPLE
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT ARE MAKING.
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY
AND SO JUST CURIOUS WHERE WE
FALL INTO THAT SO THAT'S GOOD
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES.
GENERAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT ISSUE WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
AFTER HER READY THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO REMAIN WITH US SIR
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD OF SERVICE TWO OF YOU
OKAY.
AND HAD OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
HOWARD THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
RYAN ANDERSON LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ANDERSON THANK YOU.
WHO WANTS TO PROCEED --
I GET STARTED MORNING MORNING --
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY INCLUDES A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
INCREASE. FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
THIS INCREASE REFLECTS A THREE
POINT 46% COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
IN A POINT 12% DECLINE IN
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE.
OVERALL THIS BUDGET BRINGS TOTAL
LCF OF FUNDING. TO SIXTY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
BRINGS THE TOTAL OF NEW ON GOING
FUNDING SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVE HAVE
RECEIVED.
SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
TO TWENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL NINE
BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND. FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
REFLECT A THREE POINT 46% COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
AN AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE
CHANGES UNDER THE INCLUDING THE
MINIMUM STATE AID THIS BRINGS
TOTAL LCF FUNDING FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. TO
APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS.
LASTLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET A
PROBE UP PROPOSES TO ESTABLISH A
MECHANISM.
WHEREBY THE ADMINISTRATION CAN
ASSESS THE AFFORDABILITY OF THE
COLA.
ON THE CFF FROM THEBUDGET YEAR
WITHIN THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
AND ALL OTHER SPENDING
PRIORITIES AND AUTOMATICALLY
APPLY AN ALTERNATIVE COLA TO THE
FORMULA IF NECESSARY.
WITH THEM TO BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
HELLO.
YEAH RYAN ANDERSON WITH ALEJO
AND JUST A COUPLE OF QUICK
COMMENTS.
OVERALL --
OUR OFFICE CONTINUES TO BELIEVE
THAT THE L. CFF HAS SEVERAL
ADVANTAGES.
OVER THE STATE'S PREVIOUS SCHOOL
FINANCE SYSTEM SO --
WHAT WE RECOMMEND --
SUPPORTING THE IT MAY A
PROVIDING MOST ON GOING K.
TWELVE FUNDING TO THAT FORMULA.
HOWEVER ON TWO ASPECTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS THE FIRST --
CONCERNS THIS CALL A CAB THE
FINANCE JUST MENTIONED SO THE WE
ARE WE THINK PUTTING FORWARD.
OF THIS PROPOSAL IS AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF THE REALITY
THAT THE CHANGE THE STATE MADE
LAST YEAR TO AUTOMATICALLY
PROVIDE A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT. TO THEY'LL CFF IS
NOT GOING TO BE ACTIONABLE IN
ALL BUDGET SITUATIONS THIS IS
THE SINGLE LARGEST PROGRAM.
AND THE GENERAL FUND OVER SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT NOW AND
THERE WILL BE SOME YEARS WHERE
THE STATE'S SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD.
TO PROVIDE THE FULL STATUTORY
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR
THAT AND IN FACT SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY NINETY ONE THE STATE HAS
NOT PROVIDED THE FULL STATUTORY
I K. TWELVE COLA IN ABOUT A
THIRD OF ALL YEARS.
NOW.
WE THINK RATHER THAN IMPOSING
THIS NEW --
FORMULA WHICH WILL BE DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND WILL MAKE THAT
BUDGET.
PROCESS LESS TRANSPARENT WILL WE
WOULD RECOMMEND JUST RETURNING
TO THE STATE'S TRADITIONAL
PRACTICE OF PROVIDING
AUGMENTATIONS.
ON A DISCRETIONARY BASIS JUST
EVERY YEAR --
IT YOU WILL EVALUATE THE BUDGET
CONDITION AND MAKE A DECISION
ABOUT.
CAN WE PROVIDE A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT TO THIS PROGRAM AND
IF SO WHAT SIZE OF THAT
INVESTMENT.
THE OTHER CONCERN WE HAVE --
CONCERNS THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
FORMULA AND SPECIFICALLY THE
MINIMUM STATE AID PROVISIONS SO
JUST A LITTLE BIT OF BRAD
BACKGROUND HERE.
PRIOR.
TO THIRTEEN FOURTEEN OF ONE
COUNTY OFFICES RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
THE STATE REDUCED ITS.
OF FUNDING FOR THOSE COUNTY
OFFICES DOLLAR FOR DOLLARS SO WE
WE DID NOT.
ART IN MOST CASES DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR SO WE DO NOT ALLOW COUNTY
OFFICES TO RECEIVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY GREATER
FUNDING BASED SOLELY ON THEIR
PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS.
OF WITH THE INTRODUCTION OF THE
MINIMUM STATE A PROVISION IN
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN WE PUT A CAP
ON HOW MUCH THAT STATE FUNDING
COULD BE REDUCED FOR GROWTH AND
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
AS A RESULT.
COUNTY OFFICES THAT ARE SAYING
ESPECIALLY RAPID INCREASES IN
THEIR PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS
NOW RECEIVE DISPROPORTIONATELY
GREATER.
FUNDING AMOUNTS THIS LEADS TO
SOME CONCERNS WE HAVE ABOUT
INEQUITIES IN THE IRRATIONAL
INEQUITIES IN COUNTY OFFICE.
OF FUNDING BUT WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES NOT ADEQUATELY.
I'D ACCOUNT FOR THE FULL COST OF
THIS PROVISION.
I'D.
DOUBLE.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
LONGSTANDING PRACTICE IS JUST TO
TAKE THE MOST RECENT.
DATA FOR THE COSTA MINIMUM STATE
AID AND TO HOLD THAT FLAT ACROSS
THE THREE YEARS IN THE BUDGET
WINDOW.
WHEN IN FACT WE KNOW PROPERTY
TAX VALUES ARE INCREASING UNLESS
THE THE COST OF THIS PROVISION
IS INCREASING YOUR OVER HERE OUR
OFFICES PROJECTIONS SHOW THAT?
WE WE PROJECT THAT THE FULL COST
OF THIS PROVISIONAL BE ABOUT
FORTY MILLION.
A MORE THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
CURRENTLY AUGUST ON THE LAST
PANEL IS NOT MUCH OF A CUSHION
WITHIN OUR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT PACKAGE RIGHT NOW.
SO WE DO THINK THAT THIS
UNACCOUNTED FOR COSTA SOMETHING.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING [inaudible]
AS A WELL WITH RESPECT TO THIS
WITH RESPECT TO THE SO.
SERIES AND AND THE ONES THAT --
ARE LOCATED IN AREAS WHERE
PROPERTY TAX THIS IS
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING DUE TO A
ROOM STAGGERING INCREASES IN
PROPERTY VALUES WHERE IS THAT
MONEY GO DOES IT STAY WITHIN THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION OR
WHAT.
AND SO IT DEPENDS --
TO A CERTAIN EXTENT AND THAT THE
LIMIT OF THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
FUNDING IS DECIDED BOTH BY ITS
PRIMARY FUNDING FORMULA
ENTITLEMENT AND BY ITS MINIMUM
STATE A PROVISION.
SO.
IF THERE'S STILL ROOM WITHIN --
THAT ENTITLEMENT AMOUNT THE
ADDITIONAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUE
WILL STAY WITH THE COUNTY OFFICE
SOME COUNTY OFFICES HOWEVER
CAPPED OUT --
THEIR PROPERTY TAX REVENUES ARE
SUFFICIENT TO FUND THEY'RE
ENTITLED A THIRD TOTAL LCF
ENTITLEMENT.
AND THEIR STATE FUNDING EXACTLY
EQUALS THEIR MINIMUM STATE AID
FORMULA AND THOSE CASES THE
ADDITIONAL PROPERTY TAX REVENUES
ACTUALLY RIVER TO THE COUNTY
COURTS [inaudible]
SO.
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THAT THE FOR
THOSE CUNTIES WHERE THE
PROPERTY TAX IS.
HIS HIGH IS HIGH [inaudible]
LISA RECEIPTS.
THAT THAT MONEY BE REDISTRIBUTED
TO OTHER COUNTIES THAT ARE NOT.
TO EXPERIENCING THE SAME RAPID
GROWTH IN.
PROPERTY TO AND PROPERTY VALUES
IN PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
ED SO LET MECHANISM WOULD HAVE.
TO BE SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT FROM
THAT BECAUSE PROPOSITION --
THIRTEEN LIMITS THE STATE'S
ABILITY.
TO ALLOCATE PROPERTY TAX
COLLECTIONS ACROSS STATE LINES
BUT THERE ISSUE ACTUALLY HERE IS
ON THE PROPERTY TAX VALUES THAT
THE STATE FUNDING SO THE MINIMUM
STATE AID PROVISIONS SAYS.
THAT IN THESE COUNTY IS WHERE.
PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS MIGHT
BE ENOUGH THAT WE COULD FIND THE
COUNTIES ENTITLED AN ENTIRE LCF
ENTITLEMENT WITHOUT ANY STATE
FUNDING.
THE STATE WILL STILL HAVE TO
PROVIDE THEM SOME FUNDING ON TOP
OF THAT PROPERTY TAX COLLECTION
JUST TO ENSURE.
THAT THEIR TOTAL STATE FUNDING
IS NO LESS THAN IT WAS IN.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN IF WE WERE TO
SAY I OR PUT A CAP ON IT AND SAY
FOR INSTANCE.
THAT THE MINIMUM STATE AID
PROVISIONAL NOW BE STATE FUNDING
CAN BE NO LESS THAN IT WAS AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THAT THAT WOULD NOT
FREE UP PROPERTY TAX REVENUE AND
FREE UP STATE FUNDING THAT COULD
BE ALLOCATED.
TO ANY K. TWELVE PURPOSES THAT
REQUIRE A MODIFICATION TO PROP.
NINETY EIGHT IT DOES NOT WE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DO THAT YES.
SO WE WOULD ADJUST THE AMOUNT OF
STATE FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED
OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND. TO
THESE COUNTY OFFICES.
IN QUE IN SITUATIONS WHERE THE
COUNTY PROPERTY VALUES AND
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE.
ARE EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH AND THE
COUNTY OFFICES CAN OR WE CAN
WEEK WE CAN MEET OUR MINIMUM
OBLIGATION TO TO THOSE OFFICES.
BY A COMBINATION OF A REDUCE
GENERAL FUND ALLOCATION AND THE
PROPERTY TAX THAT THEY RECEIVE
THAT'S CORRECT IN WITHIN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY A GUARANTEE
YOU WOULD THEN HAVE.
A POTENTIALLY TENS OF MILLIONS
POTENTIALLY OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION OF OF STATE FUNDING THAT.
YOU COULD DEDICATE TO ANY OTHER
CAREFUL PURPOSE YOU COULD
ALLOCATED OTHER COUNTY OFFICES
YOU CAN ALLOCATED.
SAID DISTRICTS ANY PURPOSE AT
THE LEGISLATURE'S OFFICE NOW
WITH RESPECT TO THOSE COUNTIES
WHERE THE EXCESS MONEY IS.
DISTRIBUTED TO THE COURT SYSTEM
TO HELP BY ASSUME WITH COURT
OPERATIONS WHEELER WOULD THERE
BE A CORRESPONDING IMPACT TO THE
STATE GENERAL FUND FROM THAT
SIDE.
A NO SO OUR RECOMMENDATION AGAIN
WOULD WOULD JUST BE TO AMEND THE
MINIMUM THE STATE AID PROVISION
AND THE ONLY IMPACTS THERE WOULD
BE ON STATE FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT
SO.
ANY ALLOCATIONS TO ACTUAL
PROPERTY TAX COLLECTIONS WOULD
BE UNAFFECTED BY A
RECOMMENDATION.
<c.red> UNDERSTAND IT'S A LITTLE</c>
CONFUSING.
I GET IT I THINK OKAY --
FINANCE ANY COMMENT.
I DON'T PUT YOU ON THE SPOT.
I THINK WE WOULD JUST SAY --
AND WE DON'T WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THAT PROPOSAL --
IT YET --
AND THAT THE MINIMUM CITY
PROVISION WHILE WE FEEL WAS A AN
IMPORTANT YOU KNOW PROVISION I
WAS PART OF THE DEAL THAT WAS
STRUCK AND TWELVE THIRTEEN UNDER
LCF HALF --
BUT WE HAVE NO LIKE I SAID
POSITION --
IN TERMS OF THE PROPOSAL THAT
DAILY I WAS SPEAKING OF AS FAR
AS THE THE PROJECTION GOES SO
NOT SPEAKING --
TO WHAT WHAT THE MISTER ANDERSON
WAS SPEAKING TO IN REGARDS OF
MAY BE OTHER WAYS THAT THAT
MONEY COULD BE BUDGETED FOR
OTHER PURPOSES OR WHAT HAVE YOU
WITHIN THE GUARANTEE --
SOLELY REGARDING OUR PROJECTION
THAT IS SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN IN
DISCUSSION WITH THEM ABOUT IN
TERMS OF MAYBE BETTER
IDENTIFYING WHAT THAT CHANGE
WOULD BE WE BELIEVE IT TO BE
POTENTIALLY LOAD LOW MILLIONS
LOW TENS OF MILLIONS WE ARE.
I'M SURE OF IT YOU KNOW IF WE
AGREE NECESSARILY ON SOMETHING
WE'RE LOOKING INTO AND AND
COLLABORATING WITH THEM ON SO
THAT IN IN MAY WE CAN HAVE THAT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ALL A BIT MORE
AND AND POTENTIALLY FUTURE
BUDGETS AS WELL.
SO THAT THAT'S TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT IN THE FALL FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF NINETY PACK.
THESE ARE PROP THESE ARE
PROBABLY ISSUES THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IT A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL I THINK [inaudible]
OKAY.
I HAVE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
NUMERO NOT HERE.
GENERAL THANK YOU.
BY THE WAY WILL HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE NEXT --
ISSUE WHICH IS ISSUE NUMBER
THREE STATEWIDE ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM UPDATE
.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US I WILL
ASK YOU TO INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD STARTING TO MY
LEFT IN YOUR RIGHT IF YOU'RE
READY SIR WE CAN START WITH YOU.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATED FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE SEE SEE
YOU.
MISTER MOLINA I'M TRYING TO GET
THAT ACRONYM DOWN HERE.
NUMBER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AGAIN DAN HAD ARE WITH THE
THERE CORTES WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
DAVID SEVEN BOARD OF EDUCATION.
CARICATURED UPPITY
SUPERINTENDENT CD.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US WHO
WANTS TO START.
GOOD MORNING --
SERRA CORTEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
WE WERE ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE STATE THE CAN OF
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM INCLUDING
A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF THE ROLES
AND THE ACTORS IN THE STATE
SYSTEM.
A MIDDLE SPEAK BE SPEAKING FROM
THE HANDOUT THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED
TO YOUR OWN.
SO TO START ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT THE CHANGE IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM BEGAN IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AS PART OF THE
ADOPTION OF LCF OFF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND ATTACHED TO THE LEGISLATION
THAT CREATED LC A FIVE WAS A NEW
ACCOUNTABILITY FRAMEWORK THAT'S
BEEN ROLLED OUT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
PART OF THE NEW FRAMEWORK THE
STATE ADOPTED EIGHT STATE
PRIORITY AREAS AND THESE
PRIORITY AREAS ARE LISTED ON THE
FIRST BULLET OF YOUR HAND OUT --
AND THESE ARE THE STATUTORILY
DEFINED A TESTIFIED THE KEY
THINGS THAT THE STATE THINGS ARE
MOST IMPORTANT FOR DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS TO FOCUS ON IN EACH
PRIORITY AREA IS WILLING TO
PERFORMANCE MEASURE.
THAT DETERMINE HOW WELL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS ARE DOING.
THE STATE ALSO PUTS INTO PLACE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANS --
WHERE DISTRICTS DEVELOP A PLAN
WITH GOALS AND ACTIONS ON HOW
THEY PLAN TO IMPROVE IN THE
EIGHT STATE PRIORITY AREAS?
AND DISTRICTS HAVE TO GET
FEEDBACK FROM THEIR COMMUNITIES
I'M HAVE TO GET THEIR EL CAP TO
PUT APPROVED BY THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
SO NOW PRIORITY AREAS
PERFORMANCE MEASURES AND L. CAPS
THEY ALL WORK TOGETHER SO FOR
EXAMPLE A DISTRICT FOR DISTRICT
TO DEVELOP EL CAP THEY HAVE TO
HAVE A GOAL THAT FOCUSES ON A
PRIORITY AREA SO ARE IT FOR
EXAMPLE STUDENT ENGAGEMENT. ONE
OF THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES FOR
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AS GRADUATION
RATES SO WOULD DISTRICT WILL
HAVE TO HAVE A GOAL THAT DETAILS
THE STEPS AND HOW THEY WILL
IMPROVE GRADUATION RATES IN
THEIR EL CAP.
SO MOVING ON TO PAGE TWO OF THE
HAND OUT WILL DISCUSS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
THE STATE ASSESSES IS JUST
DISTRICT PERFORMANCE THROUGH
STATUTORILY DEFINED MEASURES AND
THOSE RESULTS ARE DISPLAYED ON
THE DASHBOARD WHICH IS A
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE WEBSITE.
USING THE RESULT OF THE
DASHBOARD AT THE STATE
IDENTIFIES DISTRICTS THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE.
THE STATE LOOKS AT EVERY STUDENT
GROUP PERFORMANCE FOR EVERY
PRIORITY AREA AND IF A DISTRICT
HAS A STUDENTS SUBGROUP IN THE
LOWEST PERFORMANCE CATEGORY FOR
TWO OR MORE PRIORITY AREAS.
THERE IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING
SUPPORT.
IN THE FALL THE STATE IDENTIFIED
THREE HUNDRED ANDFORTY THREE
DISTRICTS THIRTY ONE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AS NEEDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. 65% OF THOSE
IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING SUPPORT
WAS BECAUSE THE PERFORMANCE
ISSUES WITH THEIR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES
AND THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR THAT
THE STATE HAS IDENTIFIED
DISTRICTS ON THAT NEED
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
I'M IN THE FUTURE THE STATE WILL
IDENTIFY --
DISTRICTS THAT EVE THAT NEED AN
EVEN GREATER LEVELS OF OF
SUPPORT BUT THAT SUPPORT IS
FORTHCOMING.
ON PAGE THREE OF THE HAND OUT
ALL DISCUSS THE ENTITIES
INTENDED TO SUPPORT THESE
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED AS NEEDING
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT FUNDED ENTITIES AND
ESTABLISH ROLES THAT THESE
ENTITIES WOULD HAVE IN THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
ON THESE ENTITIES INCLUDE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION WHO PROVIDE
SUPPORT DIRECTLY TO DISTRICTS.
THE COUNTY OFFICES COULD ALSO
HELP THE DISTRICT FIND A TEAM OF
EXPERTS TO SUPPORT TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND THEN THE DISTRICTS
COULD ALSO OPT OUT OF SUPPORT BY
FINDING THEIR OWN SUPPORT.
THERE'S ALSO LEAD AGENCIES
EITHER COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN L. PLAN AREAS I'M
STILL BUZZ --
AND OTHER CAL.
I'M SELF WAS AND THESE THESE
KELLY AGENCIES SUPPORT OTHER
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
DISTRICTS OR IN THE SELFLESS
CASE THAT THEY SUPPORT OTHER
SELF AS YOU MAY HEAR LEAD AGENCY
THE LEAVES REFER TO AS
GEOGRAPHICALLY THEIR SELF A
LEADS.
AND THERE'S OTHER LEADS --
BUT THESE ARE THE MAIN ONES THAT
ARE UP --
AND THEN THERE'S THE
COLLABORATIVE THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE AND THIS IS A STATE
WIDE AGENCY THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND
THE C. C. E. HELP COORDINATE
SUPPORT AMONG THE AGENCIES.
AND MAY ALSO DIRECTLY SUPPORT
DISTRICTS.
SO ON PAGE FOUR OF YOUR HANDOUT
DESCRIBES FUNDING FOR DISTRICT
SUPPORT AND THIS IS THE MJOR
ONGOING FUNDING PROVIDED FOR
THESE ENTITIES.
SO IN NINETEEN TWENTY COUNTY IN
THE NINETEEN TYPE TWENTY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION ARE PROVIDED FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE MILLION
TO SUPPORT --
THROUGH THE COUNTY OFFICE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND THIS
IS INTENDED TO SUPPORT ALL
DISTRICTS NOT JUST THOSE THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED.
AND THEN THERE'S SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION PROVIDED TO COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO SUPPORT
THOSE SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED
DISTRICTS THIS FUNDING IS
PROVIDED BASED ON A FORMULA --
THAT INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED WITH IN
EACH COUNTY AND THE SIZE OF
THOSE DISTRICTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
INCLUDES TWENTY INCLUDES A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE
FROM THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET AND THIS IS
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED.
LEAD AGENCIES THEIR PROVIDED
TECH -- TEN
MILLION FOR CELL BELIEVES AND
THEN FOR MILLION FOR COUNTY
OFFICE GEOGRAPHICALLY IT'S AND
THEN THE C. C. E. IS PROVIDED
TEN MILLION.
SO THIS IS A SYSTEM AS IT
RELATES TO PROVIDING DISTRICTS
SUPPORT --
YOUR AGENDA ALSO NOTES THE THE
STATE IS REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW
TO IDENTIFY AND SUPPORT SCHOOLS.
ON THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR THAT
SCHOOLS WERE IDENTIFIED AND THEN
THE REST OF THE PANEL WILL
PROVIDE OR SOME OF THE PANEL
WILL PROVIDE.
AN UPDATE ON THE STATE'S
PROGRESS AND SUPPORTING SCHOOL.
HOPEFULLY SOMEONE WILL COVER SO
WITH RESPECT TO THESE A REGIONAL
ROLES IN THESE LEAD AGENCIES AND
THE MONEY IS BUDGETED --
IS THERE SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IN THE SYSTEM OF
METRIC SO OF THIS --
SOME A A LEAD AGENCY FOR OUR
REGION IS IS TRACKING THE
RESULTS OF ITS EFFORTS AND AND
THE EXPENDITURE MONEY I MEAN
IT'S PRETTY BUT I WOULD IMAGINE
WITHIN A COUNTY OF OFFICE OF
EDUCATION THEY HAVE A SYSTEM OF
METRICS I JUST WONDER IF THERE
IS.
ONE THAT EXTENDS OUT TO THESE
REGIONAL THIS REGIONAL EFFORT TO
THAT FOR EXAMPLE RIVERSIDE
[inaudible]
SEVERINO.
SEE WE SEE --
EASE -- HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THEY MEASURE WHAT
THEY DO.
I'M SO THIS IS A THIS IS --
THE CC WILL BE PROVIDING AN
UPDATE --
AND THAT CAN I CAN WAIT IT OUT
AND I WAS JUST KNOW THAT THIS IS
ALL -- QUITE
NEWS OF THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTATION AS IT WAS
FOUNDED IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT SOMETIMES SOMETIMES
WE PUT MONEY IN THE PIPELINE AND
DON'T HAVE SOME.
EXPECTATIONS THE COMPANY THAT
MONEY I'M JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO.
OKAY NEXT.
THANK YOU AGAIN CHARACTER
ACTUALLY --
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION --
SO -- AT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS THE FIRST
YEAR WE RELEASED --
THE DASHBOARD --
IT BECAUSE IT WAS THE FIRST YEAR
WE SPENT A LOT OF EFFORT ON
MAKING THE THE DASHBOARD
TECHNICALLY ACCURATE AND WORKING --
APPROPRIATELY --
SO WE RECEIVED A LOT OF FEEDBACK
THAT THE DASHBOARD WASN'T AS
USER FRIENDLY --
FOR PERHAPS THE THE THE AVERAGE
PARENT OR COMMUNITY MEMBER SO --
THE THE BUDGET DIDN'T MONEY FOR
AN IMPROVEMENT OF THE DASHBOARD
WHICH WAS UNDERTAKEN LAST YEAR.
SO WE JUST RELEASED THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN DASHBOARD IN DECEMBER
WITH A NUMBER OF THESE UPGRADES
INCLUDING --
LOOKING AT THE INTERFACE ON HOW
THE DASHBOARD WORKS --
IT'S NOW FULLY TRANSLATED INTO
SPANISH --
AND WE'RE HOPING IN FUTURE YEARS
TO HAVE OTHER LANGUAGE IS --
ADDED TO THAT --
TRANSLATION WE REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF PAGES ACTUALLY IN THE
DASHBOARD BY 0%.
SO THAT --
PARENTS ESPECIALLY BUT ANYONE --
ACCESSING THE DASHBOARD IS NOT
CLICKING AWAY FROM THE SITE AND
THEN CLICKING BACK AND MOVING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN PAGES
MAKING A LOT MORE THE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE RIGHT ON
THE PAGE THAT THERE THERE ON
SOLD.
WELL -- THE
NUMBER OF OF PEOPLE THAT ARE YOU
TRACKING THAT AND THAT HAS
INCREASED.
THE FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
FROM --
PARENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS I IS
THAT IT IS MUCH MORE USER
FRIENDLY INCLUDING THE ACTUAL --
IMAGES THAT ARE USED --
TO STARTED WITH --
USING SOME CIRCLES AND SLICES OF
BOOK LIKE PIES --
AND NOW GONE TO TO SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS MORE LIKE A GAS GAUGE
THAT YOU WOULD SEE IN YOUR CAR'S
DASHBOARD SOMETHING THAT.
MOST PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH --
SO WE'VE THE FEEDBACK WE'VE
GOTTEN IS THAT --
IT IS MUCH MORE --
FRIENDLY AND FOR THE FOR THE
AVERAGE USER THE FEDS LIKE THIS.
ONE WELL THEY LIKE IT MORE THAN
THEY LIKE THE LAST ONE IN FACT
OUR OUR TO OUR TO OUR DIVISION
THAT -- IS
THAT MAINLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
HAS BEEN ASKED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PRESENT OUR DASHBOARD --
TO OTHER STATES SO --
THEY MAY NOT AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING IN THE
DASHBOARD BUT THEY DO LIKE NOW
THE DESIGN.
AND THEY DO LIKE THAT MULTIPLE
MEASURES THAT WERE USING I THINK
THE QUITE FRANKLY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S ON THE LEADING EDGE.
OF OF AN ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
IN THE DASHBOARD --
FOR PARENTS AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
STATE INDICATORS WERE THE STATE --
DEVELOP THESE CALCULATIONS AND
AND REPEATS THEM BACK OUT --
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES SOME LOCAL
INDICATORS THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTE --
TO THAT DASHBOARD LOCAL
INFORMATION THAT THE STATE
DOESN'T HALF SO THE COMBINATION
OF STATE INFORMATION AS WELL AS
LOCAL INFORMATION WHICH IS
PRETTY UNIQUE ACROSS ALL STATES
[inaudible]
AND TOMORROW.
THANK YOU ON ON THE DASHBOARD --
IT'S NICE I I LIKE IT BUT ON THE
BREAK DOWN THOSE NUMBERS EVEN
CLOSER THAN DASHBOARD --
DO YOU HAVE A PLACE FOR THE
PARENTS CAN GOAL TO SAY THEY'RE
GOING TO BE MOVING INTO A NEW
NEIGHBORHOOD NURSERY --
SCHOOLS IN THAT CITY AND THERE.
TRYING TO MOVE TO THE LOCATION
THAT IS THE BEST SCHOOL WE
ACTUALLY --
COMPARE STATISTICS SIDE BY SIDE
SO IT GETS DOWN TO THE ACTUAL.
NUMBERS.
SO WHAT WITH THERE ARE THERE ARE
A COUPLE OF THINGS WE DO NOT I
WOULDN'T SAY WE DO ANYTHING
SPECIFICALLY FOR THAT PURPOSE.
BUT WE DO WE DO HAVE SOME
FUNCTIONALITY THATASSIST WITH
THAT FOR INSTANCE YOU CAN LOOK
AT ALL THE SCHOOLS WITHIN A
DISTRICT SO.
SO IF THE IF A PARENT IS
CERTAINLY LOOKING TO MOVE THEIR
CHILD.
AT THE SCHOOLS WITH IN THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC AREA THEN THAT CAN BE
DONE THROUGH THE DASHBOARD WE DO
HAVE A FUNCTIONALITY THAT ALLOWS.
FOR A ANYONE TO COMPARE THERE'S
HOW THE STATE IS DOING OVERALL-SO YOU CAN YOU CAN MAKE THAT
COMPARISON TO SEE IF.
AT MIT AM I ABOVE I AM ABOUT THE
STATE AVERAGE OR MY BELOW THE
STATE AVERAGE WHAT WHAT WHAT
WHAT I MEAN WILL GIVE THE ACTUAL
PERCENTAGES PER SCHOOL OF
BREAKING DOWN AND MATH SCIENCES.
SCIENCE --
INFLATION COMPARED WITH OTHER
SCHOOLS.
THE ACTUAL NUMBERS.
RIGHT SO SO I AM NOT SURE I
QUITE UNDERSTAND THE THE THE
QUESTION BUT THERE ARE LOW.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THERE IS A
LOT OF ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
COMPARE --
WITHIN A DEBT THE SCHOOLS WITHIN
A DISTRICT WHICH IS WHERE MOST
PARENTS ARE LOOKING AT THE OTHER
THING THAT THAT I THINK IT DOES
IS -- IT HAS
THAT THAT DASHBOARD WITH A
NUMBER OF GAUGES FOR ALL OF
THOSE MULTIPLE --
MEASURES THE DIFFERENT
INDICATORS THAT WE HAVE IN A
SINGLE PLACE.
BECAUSE WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
IS THAT PARENTS WANT TO CHOOSE A
SCHOOL FOR A PARTICULAR REASON
OFTEN --
THEY MAY BE INTERESTED IN
ACADEMICS AND THEY WANT TO LOOK
AT THE ASSESSMENT.
RESULTS BUT MAYBE WHAT THEY'RE
MOST INTERESTED IN IS IS THE IS
THE SCHOOL HAVE A GOOD --
COMMUNITY RIGHT IS THERE IS
THERE IS THERE --
HOW HOW IS THE SAFETY RIGHT SO
WITH SO ONE OF THE SUSPENSION
RATES LOOK LIKE IN THAT SCHOOL
OR PERHAPS THERE --
PARENT OF AN ENGLISH LEARNERS SO
THEY WANT.
A CATEGORY SO IT BY DOING THAT
MULTIPLE MEASURES IT DOES ALLOW
PARENTS TO FOCUS ON A SINGLE
MEASURE AS WELL AS LOOKING AT
OVERALL HOW A SCHOOL IS DOING --
SO I WISH I COULD CONTINUE.
SO -- WE DID --
SERVE AN INTERACTIVE PROCESS.
I APPRECIATE THAT SO --
WE DID IDENTIFY --
DISTRICTS --
SERRA WAS SAYING --
FOR DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE I
WON'T GO INTO THE ACTUAL NUMBERS
IN THE DETAILS THEY ARE IN IN
YOUR INFORMATION BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY ADDRESS THOSE IF.
IF IF YOU HAVE --
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
USING THE LOCAL CONTROL --
FOR A UNDING FORMULA AND THE
THE PHILOSOPHY BEHIND THAT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT --
I THINK HISTORY.
EXPERIENCE --
AND SOME SOME STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
US THAT --
HAVING DECISIONS MADE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AS LOCAL AS POSSIBLE
I HAS A BETTER CHANCE OF BEING
SUCCESSFUL AND SUSTAINABLE WHICH
IS IMPORTANT --
FOR MAKING CHANGES AND
IMPROVEMENTS --
IN IN SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
HAVING THAT THE OLD SYSTEM UNDER
NCLB WAS VERY TOP DOWN IT WAS
VERY -- DC
SACRAMENTO I DIRECTED FOR WHAT
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS HAD TO DO
I WAS VERY SPECIFIC STEPS ONCE
THEY WERE IDENTIFIED.
THIS MUCH MORE PUTS THE
OWNERSHIP DOWN INTO THE
COMMUNITY INTO COUNTY OFFICES
WHERE THE SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
ARE LOCATED SO THAT THEY CAN IN
FACT ASSIST THEM BECAUSE WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND.
IS THAT IF A IF A SCHOOL FOR
INSTANCE IS NOT DOING WELL IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS THERE MAY
BE MULTIPLE REASONS FOR THAT
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE REASON.
IT COULD BE THE INSTRUCTION BUT
IT COULD BE MATERIALS IT COULD
BE --
STUDENT ATTENDANCE IT COULD BE
THIS AT THE SAFETY IN THE SCHOOL
THERE COULD BE A LOT OF REASONS
SO YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO MAKE THE
BEST DECISIONS AND THE DATA --
THAT GOES WITH THAT LOCAL.
COMMUNITY SO MOVING AWAY AS WE
HAVE FROM AND SEE --
BE -- TO THE
NEW --
FEDERAL REAUTHORIZATION **** OUT
EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT IT
DOES ALLOW FOR A MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WHICH
WE'VE DONE TO A GREAT DEAL OF
EXTENT TO THE X. GREATEST EXTENT.
POSSIBLE --
THERE ARE STILL SOME DISCONNECTS
BETWEEN --
WHAT CALIFORNIA?
WOULD LIKE TO BUT WE HAVE
COMBINED THOSE IN A SINGLE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM.
SALAS AGAIN SERRA WAS MENTIONING --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRES
US TO IDENTIFY SCHOOLS --
FOR FOR IMPROVEMENT AND SO WE
HAVE DONE THAT AS OF JANUARY --
WE STILL THINK THAT THE THE
AGENCY OF CHANGE IS GOING TO BE
THE DISTRICT NOT THE INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL -- I
THINK AGAIN RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
US UNDER NCLB THAT IF YOU FOCUS
DOWN TO A SCHOOL LEVEL FROM THE
STATE TO THE SCHOOL --
YOU CAN MAKE SMALL AMOUNT OF
CHANGES FOR A SMALL AMOUNT OF
TIME BUT IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE
REALLY HAVE TO BUILD CAPACITY IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. TO HELP THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I HELP THEIR SCHOOLS AND SUSTAIN
WHATEVER GAINS THEY CAN MAKE SO --
THOSE WERE ALSO IDENTIFIED AS
AND AGAIN SERRA WAS MENTIONING --
THERE WITH THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET PUTTING MONEY INTO THE
COUNTY OFFICES OF THE COUNTY
OFFICES CAN HELP BUILD THE
CAPACITY IN THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SO THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN
HELP THEMSELVES.
AND HELP THEIR SCHOOLS --
IS WHAT HAS JUST --
BEGAN OTHER --
CDP THE STATE BOARD CCE ARMY
TOGETHER REGULARLY AND MEET WITH
THESE LEAD TO THE AGENCIES THAT
AGAIN SERRA WAS MENTIONING. TO
COORDINATE THE EFFORTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE EFFORTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE CALIBRATED --
AND TO OUR AND FOLKS ARE TALKING
TO EACH OTHER BECAUSE THERE ARE
MULTIPLE --
LEAD AGENCIES AND OF COURSE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES THAT WE
HAVE TO WORK AND SO I THINK I'LL
STOP THERE AND THE WHAT SO
WHAT'S THE RIVER HOW DO WE
WHAT'S THE METRIC.
IN THIS NEW --
DOES.
WE HAVE ISSUE EASES REGIONAL
LEADS.
WHAT'S THE METRIC AND WHAT'S THE
REPORTING PROCESS THAT WE HAVE
THE DASHBOARD FOR INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOLS CRACK WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
REPORTING METRIC HERE AND HOW DO
WE KNOW WHETHER THIS.
NEW SYSTEM IS AFFECTED BY GUESS
OBVIOUSLY ONE MEASURE IS IF THE
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS.
TURN FROM RED TO GREEN ON YOUR
DASHBOARD.
BUT THERE MAY BE REASONS OTHER
REASONS WHY THEY DON'T GO FROM
RED TO GREEN AND THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT INDICATE OF A FAILURE OR
INADEQUATE.
INADEQUATE PERFORMANCE ON THE
PART OF THE REGIONAL LEAD SO.
AT SOME POINT SOMEONE CAN
ADDRESS THAT BUT SIR PLEASE
PROCEED.
DAVID SEVEN STABLE OF
EDUCATIONAL JUST ADDRESS THAT
CA MR MOLINO THAT.
LEGISLATION THAT ENACT IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET THAT ENACTED THE
LEAD AGENCY STRUCTURE.
INCLUDED A REQUIREMENT TO HAVE
SPECIFIC METRICS THAT EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF EACH OF THE
ACTORS WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
SO AS MISS CORTEZ MENTIONED THIS
IS JUST THE FIRST YEAR THIS THE
FINAL THIRD OF GROUP OF LEADS
WERE SELECTED IN JANUARY.
SO THAT PROCESS OF IDENTIFYING
SORT OF WHAT THE RIGHT METRIC IS
GIVENTHE DIFFERENT GROUPS FOCUS
OF EACH LEAD IS GOING TO BE
FINALIZED BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR TO BE USED THROUGHOUT THE
FIVE YEAR TERM OF THE GRANT --
BUT THE STATUTE ACTUALLY
REQUIRED AT A MINIMUM THAT THE
METRICS INCLUDE THE NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS WITHIN THE AREA THAT
ARE BEING IDENTIFIED FOR SYSTEMS
AND WHETHER THEY'RE IMPROVING.
AS A ONE MEASURE BUT WITH THE
GOAL IS TO HAVE MULTIPLE
MEASURES THAT LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT ROLES AND FUNCTIONS
THAT THESE LEAD AGENCIES HAVE
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
KNOW.
IF THE SCHOOLS ARE GOING FROM
RED TO GREEN.
WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE OF A
PROBLEM AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL.
OR IT IS YOU INDICATED WHETHER
IT'S A PROBLEM AT THE DISTRICT
LEVEL OR THE COUNTY.
OFFICE OF EDUCATION LEVEL IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM IS
THAT MONEY IS IT PEOPLE IS IT
TECHNIQUE IS AND WHATEVER AND
GOOD I LOOK FORWARD.
TO SEEING THE METRICS AND
ULTIMATELY IF I'M AROUND LONG
ENOUGH SEEING A REPORT YES SIR
THANK YOU I WAS JUST GONNA SAY
BEFORE AGAIN TOM OR MOLINA
AT JUST TO CLARIFY --
ASIDE FROM SCHOOLS HAVING
DASHBOARDS DISTRICTS HAVE
DASHBOARDS COUNTIES HAVE
DASHBOARDS ARE AND WE HAVE STATE
AVERAGES AS WELL SO --
EVERY EVERYONE IS BEING MEASURED
AS WELL AS THREE THE SPECIFIC
REPORTING THAT DAVID SAP WAS
REFERRING.
TO GOOD LUCK LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE RESULTS OF THIS
EFFORT.
NEXT TIME YES AND SANTA MARLENA
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE WHEN OUR
FOURTH YEAR AND EXISTENCE --
WHEN I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT IS ABOUT THE WORK
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN
PARTICULAR WE'VE BEEN HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION?
THIS MORNING AROUND THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEMS ONE OF THE
TWO HAND OUTS THAT WE PROVIDED.
THE FIRST IS JUST A DIAGRAM THAT
EXPLAINS THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEMS
FOR ALMOST ON A LOT OF TIME ON
THAT BECAUSE I COULD SPEND A LOT
OF TIME ON THAT BUT I I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE SOME
BASIC UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THAT
SYSTEM IS.
IS REALLY BILL TO WORK IN A
PARTICULAR YOU'LL NOTICE --
THAT THE ELEAZAR THE MIDDLE IN
THE WAY THAT THIS IS BUILT IS
THAT FIRST LAYER SUPPORT IS
INTENDED TO BE THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION THE CANAL
SOPHISTICATION GETS FUNDING.
IN PARTICULAR TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THEIR DISTRICTS IN PARTICULAR
THOSE.
WHO IDENTIFIED IN THE DASHBOARD
IS IN NEED OF SERVICE IN THAT
SERVICES OFF ON IS NOW
CONSIDERED DIFFERENCES SYSTEMS
WE FOR THAT?
TOPIC.
WHAT THAT LEVEL OF ASSISTANCE IS?
THE SIMPLEST WAY TO THINK ABOUT
IT IS.
THERE ARE THERE ARE THERE ON THE
DASHBOARD FOR A PARTICULAR AREA
THE THING MAY BE STRUGGLING AND
COULD BE A SUBGROUP IT COULD BE
AS THE SPECIFIC --
SUBJECT AREA THE COUNTY OFFICE
GOES AND MEETS WITH THEM THEY
TRY TO IDENTIFY WHAT OF WHAT
THEY CONSIDER THE ROOT CAUSES.
OF OF WHY STUDENTS MAY BE
STRUGGLING AND THEN THEY HELP
THEM DEVISE A NEW PLAN AND
RESOURCES. TO HAVE WAYS TO GO
AHEAD AND ATTACK THAT PROBLEM
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE TO THE
SYSTEMS PIECE AND THEN WHEN THEY
REVIEW THEIR EL CAP IN THE
FOLLOWING.
YEAR THAT THEY'VE THE HOLES WE
PUT THOSE STRATEGIES INTO THAT
AL CAPP IN THE CONTINUE MOVING
IN THAT DIRECTION.
THE NEXT SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IS
THE GEOGRAPHICALLY AGENCIES.
AND THESE ARE THE AGENCIES THAT
WERE CHOSEN THIS YEAR --
JUST CHOSEN IN THE FALL.
OUR AGENCY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS WELL
AS THE STATE BOARD OF ED STAFF --
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR CHOOSING
THOSE FOR READING THEM TOGETHER
AND THEN MAKING THAT SELECTION
THEY ARE ALL RESPONSIBLE FOR A
GROUP OF OTHER COUNTY OFFICES
AROUND SOME GEOGRAPHIC
BOUNDARIES.
AND THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY COUNTY
OFFICE HAS THAT CAPACITY TO BE
ABLE TO DEVELOP THAT GIVE THAT
ASSISTANCE TO A DISTRICT.
THAT IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
CAPACITY TO HELP BUILD THAT
CAPACITY OR THE PROVIDE THAT
RESOURCE SOME OTHER WAY --
THE THIS TO THEMSELVES OR SOME
OTHER ANOTHER COUNTY OFFICE OR
HE COULD BE TO THE C. C. AS WELL.
THE NEXT ALL THE OTHER FOLKS
THAT ARE ON THE ON THE EDGE OF
THAT OUR OTHER LEAD AGENCIES
SOME OF THEM HAVE ALREADY BEEN
EXISTENCE --
OTHER ONES ARE NEW THIS YEAR AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT IS A NEW
INITIATIVE THE CELLPHONE
RESOURCE LEADS ARE NEW THIS WELL
SOME OF THE OTHER FOLKS --
ARE ALSO KNEW SO THEY HAVE
SPECIFIC SPECIALTIES WHERE THEY
HAVE SHOULD THEY PROVEN THAT
THEY HAVE SOME EXPERTISE IN A
PARTICULAR AREA.
SO THAT THE WAY I WAS REFERRED
TO DO SO IF THERE'S A LOCAL
AGENCY AGENCIES THERE'S A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT HAS A NEED.
AND IS A COUNTY OFFICE GOES IN
AND STARTS TO WORK WITH THEM AND
DETERMINES THAT WHAT THEY NEED
IS.
THERE'S A RESPONSIBILITY OF
THESE GEOGRAPHIC LEADS WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO KNOW WHAT THOSE
EXPERTISE.
ARE AND THEN BE ABLE TO MAKE
SURE THAT COUNTY OFFICE WOULD
HAVE THAT ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THAT EXPERTISE TO THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THE OTHER PIECE TO IS TO MAKE
SURE I KNOW I WAS JUST I WAS A
FORMER COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT UP
IN SHASTA.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE ARE ONE OF
THE BIGGER COUNTY OFFICE IN OUR
REGION.
AND SO WE A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESOURCES AND SO WE HAD OTHER
SOME OF OUR PARTNERS IN MODOC
AND TWENTY WERE PRETTY SMALL SO.
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED TO DO THIS
WORK AROUND DIFFERENCES SYSTEMS
WE DID QUITE A BIT OF WORK TO
HELP THEM BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE SAME AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES?
THAT WAS JUST BECAUSE WE HAD
SOME PARTNERSHIPS IS AS
COLLEAGUES THIS SYSTEM.
SURE ISN'T THAT WILL HAPPEN AND
THAT'S THE ONE THAT'S IN
PARTICULAR THOSE GEOGRAPHICALLY
AGENCIES ARE OUR ROLE WITHIN
THAT WITH THE CD IN PARTICULAR
IS SELL CORDONING FACILITATE
THAT.
SO WE HAD TO CHOOSE THOSE FOLKS
WE HAVE TO BRING THOSE THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WORK
WE HAVE TO HELP THEM --
TO SOME OF THE EVALUATION AROUND
THAT WORK AND MAKE SURE THAT
THAT SYSTEM ACTUALLY WORKS.
SO I CAN ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
SYSTEMS OR JUST LOOKING AT YOUR
HAND -- I'M
JUST CURIOUS MAYBE IT'S THIS
WHOLE THING IS TO NEW BUT HOW
MANY -- HOW-MANY ELEAZAR IN LEVEL THREE
INTENSIVE INTERVENTIONS NONE?
YES NONE AT THIS TIME SO THE THE
LEVEL TWO IS WERE AROUND THE
VERY FIRST WEEK AND MANY BECAUSE
WERE AND AS YOU SAID IT'S REALLY
IN THE SYSTEM SO WE ONLY HAVE
TWO YEARS WORTH OF DATA.
SO TO BE A LEVEL THREE THAT
WOULD TAKE SOME TIME BE ABLE TO
GET THERE.
I GUESS THAT'S A GOOD THING THAT
IS A GOOD THING.
OKAY SO THE NEXT PIECE OF THOSE
SHARE WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT IS --
OWN I'M SORRY SO THE OTHER HAND
OUT TO THIS IS JUST FOR YOUR
REFERENCE THESE ARE THE LEAD
AGENCIES SO YOU CAN LOOK AT
THOSE ANOTHER TIME.
BUT THAT JUST SHOWS YOU WHO ARE
THOSE COUNTY OFFICES IN THE
OTHER FOLKS THAT ARE HAVE BEEN
CHOSEN.
AND A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THEY
DO ON THE VERY BACK [inaudible]
TO GOOD.
THE SECOND PIECE IS THE WORK
AROUND IN PARTICULAR I'M A LOOK
AT OUR PARTNERSHIP SO.
WE WERE ASKED TO BRING TOGETHER
VARIOUS --
DISTRICTS A DISTRICTS WERE
AWESOME AND AND THOSE WHO AND
MAYBE BEEN STRUGGLING
ACADEMICALLY SO WE WE WERE ASKED
TO DO SOME WORK WITH SOME PILOT
DISTRICTS DISTRICTS.
TO WHO EIGHTY NINETY STRUGGLING
OR TRYING TO GET BETTER
ACADEMICALLY SOME OF THE PAST
FEW YEARS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH ELEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
BRINGING THEM TOGETHER AND
REALLY TRYING TO HELP THEM.
DEVELOP SOME STRATEGIES TO GET
BETTER ACADEMICALLY SO AND AGAIN
VERY MUCH LIKE --
THE DIFFERENCES ASSISTANCE SOME
OF THEIR DASH DASH FOR RESULTS
SO OUR WORK WITH THEM WILL
FINISH THIS YEAR IT WAS FUNDED
ARE FUNDING ENDS THIS YEAR.
SO WE WILL HAVE A REPORT TO COME
OUT IN THE FALL AND WILL HAVE
SOME PRETTY GOOD DATA TO BE ABLE
TO SHOW SOME SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
WE MADE IN THOSE DISTRICTS.
PART OF THE GOAL AROUND THAT
WORK IS TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
EXAMPLES OF WHERE WE DONE THAT
WORK TO WEAR AS DISTRICTS OTHER
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
MAYBE START TO HAVE SOME OF THE
STRUGGLES.
WILL HAVE A RESOURCE FOR SOME
PRACTICES WERE WE CAN BE ABLE TO
USE SOME OF THOSE SAME
STRATEGIES TO HELP OTHER
DISTRICTS.
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY YOU IS A NEW
BILL THAT WAS PASSED IN AUGUST
AND SO THESE ARE THE DISTRICTS
IN THE STATE WHO ARE IN
RECEIVERSHIP WHICH RESERVE A
STATE LOAN --
AND SO WITH THE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN FORTY FOR THE FIRST
TIME AND THERE'S THE LANGUAGE
THAT SAYS THAT WHEN A DISTRICTS
IS IN RECEIVERSHIP TO THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE --
HAS AND HAS SOME RESPONSIBILITY
GOING START WORKING WITH THEM
ACADEMICALLY SO WE HAVE BEEN
DOING THAT WORK --
SINCE SEPTEMBER IN PARTICULAR
WITH THE INGLEWOOD AND VALLEJO
CITY OF THE DISTRICTS WE'VE
WORKED PRETTY STRONGLY AND WE
WERE ALREADY IN THOSE DISTRICTS.
A BASED ON IN INGLEWOOD THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT ASKED US TO
GO IN THERE LAST SPRING.
AND THEN AND THEN VALLEJO CITY
THE ACTUALLY THE DISTRICT IN THE
COUNTY SUPER **** TO COMMAND --
WE'RE JUST STARTING TO DO SOME
WORK THE COUNTY OFFICE TO THEIR
DIFFERENCES ASSISTANCE.
AS WELL AND SO WE'RE DOING QUITE
A BIT TO SPENDING QUITE A BIT OF
TIME IN PUTTING A LOT OF
RESOURCES.
AND REALLY TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE DISTRICTS ARE.
ARE --
ATTACKING THE ACADEMIC ISSUES
WHAT WITH A FOUND IN THOSE
DISTRICTS AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IS
IS WHEN THERE'S FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTIES STUDENTS DON'T DO
AS WELL.
AND SO THEY'VE SEEN OVER THE
YEARS AT THE ANY DISTRICT IT'S
EVER BEEN IN RECEIVERSHIP AS
ACADEMIC ISSUES AS WELL SO
EIGHTEEN FORTY RECOGNIZES THAT.
SAID LET'S PUT CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE IN THERE SO WE CAN
WHILE WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS THAT
WE CAN HELP THE DISTRICT FIGURE
OUT HOW THEY'RE GOING TO GET
BETTER FINANCIALLY.
WE CAN ALSO BE HELPING STUDENTS
AT SAME TIME OFTEN THE PAST THE
FOCUS IS BEEN SPECIFICALLY ON
THE FINANCIAL ISSUES IN THE
ACADEMIC ISSUES CONTINUE TO GET
WORSE YES SO PERHAPS.
PERHAPS YOU COULD NOT TO BELABOR
THIS BECAUSE WE CAN DO IT SOME
OTHER TIME BUT CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN
ME WHY IS THAT. FOR EXAMPLE IN A
DISTRICT IT'S IN RECEIVERSHIP --
SOME WOULD ARGUE THAT SOME OF
THEM WERE IN RECEIVERSHIP
BECAUSE OF THE IMHO USE THAT
WERE NEGOTIATED IN THE SALARY
AND BENEFIT PACKAGES THAT WERE
PAID. TO A VARIETY OF FOLKS FROM
THE TOP TO THE BOTTOM.
OTHERS CAN HAVE THAT DEBATE BUT
TEACHERS ARE BEING PAID.
IN THE CLASSROOM.
EDUCATING STUDENTS HAVE YOU BEEN
ABLE TO DETERMINE WHY THERE IS A
DROP IN ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES I
UNDERSTAND THE DROP IN FINANCIAL
PERFORMANCE SHOW THAT'S WHETHER
SHE WISHES.
BUT IS THERE IS THERE A DIRECT
CONNECTION.
AND HOW DOES THAT WORK THERE IS
IN EVERY EVERY JUST BECAUSE THIS
IS DIFFERENT THERE ARE SOME
COMMONALITIES IN PARTICULAR WITH
THESE DISTRICTS.
MOST EARN I HAVE HAD SEVERE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT INGLEWOOD
FOR EXAMPLE IS LOST OVER TEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS LIKE EIGHT
YEARS SO THAT'S THAT'S SOMETIMES
OVER A THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
YEAR.
SO THEY'RE HAVING TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS QUICKLY AND THEY'RE
IN THERE OFTEN REDUCING THINGS
WITHOUT.
BEING ABLE TO GET SOME REAL
CONSIDERATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO REDUCE
AND SO OFTEN THAT WHAT WE'RE
FINDING IS WE'RE GOING IN AND
DOING THESE ACADEMIC REVIEWS.
IS THERE THERE MAY BE SOME GOOD
PRACTICES ARE SOME GOOD THINGS
HAPPENING THEY MAY HAVE
INSTRUCTIONAL COACH IS WHAT HAVE
YOU BUT THEY DON'T HAVE A REALLY
STRONG DATA SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE.
SO OFTEN THE REDUCTIONS THAT
THEY'RE MAKING AS TO WHAT THOSE
THINGS ARE IN SOME OF THOSE
REDUCTIONS.
COULD BE KEY TO THE SUCCESS
THEY'VE HAD IN THE PAST.
IN SO THE SOMETIMES REDUCING THE
WRONG THINGS --
AND SO THERE THE END I THINK
IT'S BECAUSE I HAVEN'T RESPOND
VERY QUICKLY HE ALSO THE
TURNOVERS SIGNIFICANT.
IN THE WOULD FOR EXAMPLE IS
THEIR CABINET LEVEL TEAM RIGHT
NOW THIS IS THE FIRST YEAR IN
THE LAST EIGHT YEARS THE SAME
PEOPLE THAT THE TABLE.
THIS GOING TO TURN OVER PEOPLE
LEAVE AND SO BECAUSE OF THAT
THERE'S THERE'S A CREDIBLE
MODERN -- IN
COHERENCE IF YOU WILL THAT EXIST --
SO OVER FINDING IS WE'RE GOING
IN THERE IS THAT OFTEN THERE MAY
BE.
SOME EXAMPLES OF SOME GOOD
THINGS HAPPENING BUT IT'S NOT
SYSTEM ACROSS THE DISTRICT SIGN
HAPPENING IN EVERY SCHOOL WILL
GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE MAY SEE
MORE OF THESE.
IN THIS ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE
LIVING IN.
AND UNDERSTANDING THAT.
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT PRESSURES
AND DIFFERENT.
ISSUES DO YOU THINK WE WILL.
NEVERTHELESS BE ABLE --
WITH YOUR INVOLVEMENT --
YOUR ENTITIES INVOLVEMENT
DEVELOP SORT OF A TEMPLATE FOR
HOW.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SHOULD RESPOND.
THE FINANCIAL ISSUES WILL BE
HANDLED BY SOMEBODY ELSE BUT
HAVE THE DISTRICT SHOULD BE RID
SHOULD RESPOND UNDER THESE
PARTICULAR CIRCUMSTANCES FROM AN
ACADEMIC.
STANDPOINT YES IN OTHER WORDS
GENERALLY YOU SHOULDN'T REDUCE
HERE THIS IS WHAT I NEED TO DO
AND SORT OF A CHECKLIST FOR
SUPERINTENDENTS AS THEY AS THEY
MOVE OR THE OR THE RECEIVER --
AS THEY MOVE THROUGH THE SYSTEM
TO TRY TO RESTORE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY TO THE DISTRICT YES
SIR TWO EXAMPLES OF THAT ONE IS
I MENTION THESE ACADEMIC REVIEWS.
OR FINDING IS WERE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE ACADEMIC
REVIEWS THAT WE'RE DOING THE ANY
JUST TO COULD DO SO SCHOOLS.
RIGHT AND THAT OUR GOAL WOULD BE
IS TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
COUNTY OFFICES TO YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT. TO YOUR IN RECEIVERSHIP
RIGHT NOW THE COUNTY OFFICES I
GUESS A IS A COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT I KNEW WHICH MY
DISTRICT ARE DOING BETTER THAN
OTHERS.
I HAD SOME SENSE LOCALLY OF SO
WE THINK THAT TOOL CAN ACTUALLY
BE VERY HELPFUL TO GO IN AND
MAKE SURE BECAUSE IT LOOKS --
IT IT IDENTIFIES WHAT ARE SOME
KEY THINGS YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE IN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR MAKE SURE THE
STUDENTS ARE DOING WELL
ACADEMICALLY.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MEASURE THOSE
KEY AREAS AND WE LOOK TO SEE
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AS WELL IN
THIS AREA THEY'RE DOING FAIRLY
WELL IN THIS SERIOUS EACH WEEK
THIS DID THIS OR DID THIS MORE
CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE
DISTRICTS SO THEY HAVE SOMETHING
THEY CAN LOOK AT TO GO.
AHEAD AND ATTACK THE PROBLEM NOW.
SO THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE OF THE OF
THE PIECE THAT WORD WITH A COLD --
REALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE THE
OTHER PIECE OF GIVING EXAMPLES
SOME OF OUR INITIAL WORK IN
OAKLAND.
THIS KIND OF VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT YOU WERE SUGGESTING OAKLAND
IS HAVING TO MAKE SEVERE
REDUCTIONS RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
HAVING THE CUT.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WHICH MEANS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
CUT INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAM TOO SO
ONE OF THE THINGS OAKLAND ****
TO DO AND THEN AND THEN ALAMEDA
COUNTY OFFICE OF THAT SAID.
IS COULD YOU SIT WITH US COULD
YOU LOOK AT OUR EL CAP COULD YOU
LOOK AT OUR RESULTS COULD YOU
LOOK AT THE AREAS IN THERE THAT
YOU THINK --
ARE SIGNIFICANT TO THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO MAKE TO BE ABLE TO HELP
STUDENTS.
AND SO WITH US TO LOOK AT WORD
OVER SUGGESTING WE WOULD REDUCE
AND THEN LOOK AT IS THAT THE
RIGHT THING TO REDUCE.
RIGHT IF WE REDUCE THAT SHOULD
BE REDUCES INSTEAD BECAUSE IT'S
A KEY AREA THAT'S LISTEN ARE EL
CAP AND THEN HELP US AS WE
DESIRE --
KEPT GOING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE KEY AREAS OF THEIR SO
SIMILAR THOUGHT PARTNER RIGHT TO
BEING ABLE THOUGHTFUL DECISION
WHEN THEY'RE SITTING THERE TO
MAKE THE CUTS SO JUST TRYING TO
DO IT ON THEIR OWN.
AND SO HOW DO YOU DISTILL ALL
THIS AND AND THEN DISSEMINATED
PUSH IT PUSH IT OUT AS OPPOSED
TO SIMPLY POSTED ON A WEBSITE.
PUSH IT OUT AS BEST PRACTICES --
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
STATEWIDE EVERY WEEK.
IN THE ACT IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME
SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE MILITARY
BUT HERE IN THE WAY BACK --
THERE WAS A LOT OF CROSS FEET I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE CALL IN
THOSE DAYS OF BEST PRACTICES
FROM BASE TO BASE FROM UNIT TO
UNIT FROM COMMANDED COMMAND SO.
IF I WAS ON THE WEST COAST I
COULD SEE WHAT SOME COMMAND ON
THE EAST COAST.
WAS DOING IN VARIOUS AREAS AND
pAND WHAT.
THIS ESSENTIALLY WAS A BEST
PRACTICE AND I COULD DECIDE
WHETHER IT FIT MY PARTICULAR
SITUATION OR NOT AND THEN
IMPLEMENT.
IT DO YOU PUSH THIS INFORMATION
OUT IN A IN A IN A FORM THAT'S
DISTILLED SO SOMEONE CAN.
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE AND DECIDE
WHETHER IT APPLIES.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY AND I WILL TELL
YOU THE THE KEY TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING I REALLY BELIEVE IS ON
THE OF THIS BILL SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT.
THE SYSTEM WAS FORTY REALLY BILL.
TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER SO
THEY'RE NO LONGER WORK IN
ISOLATION RIGHT IN THE KEY PIECE
TO THAT IS COUNTY OFFICES.
SO FOR US IN PARTICULAR OUR WORK
IS.
THE MORE THAT WE CAN WORK
COLLECTIVELY WOULD COUNTY OFFICE
WHO CAN THEN USE THOSE SAME
RESOURCES TO GET INTO DISTRICTS
WITHIN THEIR COUNTY THERE'S
THERE'S THERE'S A MUCH BIGGER
CHANCE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND UP HERE OUT IN OUR OWN
TRYING TO GET INTO A DISTRICT SO
I REALLY THINK THE SYSTEM IS SET
UP FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
IN PARTICULAR THAT WE'RE IN AND
IT'S I THINK IT'S JUDY THAT US
WITH THE CD ARE ARE BEING ASKED
TO BE WITH THEM TO HELP
FACILITATE THAT SO.
NOT ONLY ARE WE A FACILITATOR
BUT WE HAVE RESOURCES AT THE
SAME TIME WERE IN SOME SENSE
COULD BE A LEAD.
YOU KNOW AND SOME OF THIS WORK
AROUND SYSTEMIC.
SO PERIODICALLY AS PART OF THIS
WHOLE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IN YOUR
ROLE IN IT YOU DO IN FACT PUSH
OUT --
INNOCENT SURELY DO LESSONS FOR
SUCCESS WE DO A NEEDS THE
EXAMPLE OF THAT IS TO IF YOU
LOOK AT THE OTHER.
SIDE OF THAT PIECE OF PAPER WE
WE DO THESE P. L. AND NETWORKS
WHICH ARE.
WE HAVE FIFTY FIVE OF THEM WHICH
ARE BASICALLY GROUPS OF FOLKS
WITH COUNTY OFFICES IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO COME TOGETHER --
TRYING TO ATTACK A SPECIFIC
PROBLEM WE LEAVE THAT WORK WITH
THEM IN ADDITION WE'RE
DEVELOPING WHAT WE CALL THESE
TOOLKITS YOU CAN SEE SOME OF
THOSE SUBJECT AREAS.
THAT ARE LISTED THERE ONE FOR
EXAMPLE IS AROUND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT DEVELOPING
WE'VE SOME BEST RESOURCES THAT
FOLKS COULD BE ABLE TO USE OUR
FREE.
THE DISTRICT PARTICIPATED SAY
HERE ARE SOME RESOURCES YOU CAN
CONSIDER USING AROUND CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND COUNTY OFFICES
ARE HELPING US DETERMINE THOSE
AS WELL AS WE USE IN THE DASH
FOR RESULTS.
THE CHARTER THE TERM IN ONE OF
THOSE AREAS THAT WE SHOULD TO
PROVIDE SOME EXAMPLES OF SOME
BEST PRACTICES.
PERFECT.
THANK YOU SIR YOU'RE WELCOME
[inaudible]
WHO'S NEXT.
THE MORNING GIVE SEPARATE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION AGAIN I'M
JUST GONNA I THINK CLOSE THE
UPDATE PART OF THIS BY TALKING
ABOUT SORT OF HOW THESE PIECES
FIT TOGETHER AND THE ONGOING
WORK TO UPDATE IMPROVE THE
SYSTEM AS WE GO --
AS MISS COURT HAS MENTIONED THAT --
I'LL SEE IF I WAS PASSED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND WE'RE NOW
SIX YEARS THEN AND THERE WAS
ACTUALLY A VERY INTENTIONAL
STAGED IMPLEMENTATION BUILT INTO
THE STATUTE.
THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS
THAT YOU'VE HEARD REFERENCE THE
STATE BOARD WAS REQUIRED TO
ADOPT THE TEMPLATE FOR THOSE
PLANS AND JANET BY JANUARY OF%
TWENTY FOURTEEN SO THERE'S BEEN
THEIR OFFICIALLY THREE YEARS OF
LOCAL PLANNING WITHOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF THE DASHBOARD OR
THE SYSTEM TO SUPPORT THE MISTER
ON MOLINA.
DESCRIBED IN THROUGH THAT --
THAT THE BOARD DIG THE BOARD WAS
CHARGED WITH ADOPTING THE
TEMPLATE FOR THOSE PLANS IS THAT
WHEN THE DASHBOARD WAS RELEASED
THE BOARD UPDATED THE TEMPLATE
TO ENSURE THAT THE CONNECTION
AND LINKAGE BETWEEN THOSE TO SET
THE EXPECTATION ALL LONG.
WAYS THAT THE LOCAL PLAN WOULD
BE INFORMED BY STATE LEVEL DATA
RELATIVE TO SOME OBJECTIVE
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
AND IS MISS CORTEZ MENTIONED
THERE TWENTY ONE MEASURES THAT
HAVE TO BE TRACKED IN THIS LOCAL
PLANS.
HOW DO WE IDENTIFY A SUBSET OF
THOSE OF THOSE YOU KNOW KEY
CRITICAL MEASURES ON A STATEWIDE
BASIS?
AND AT THAT WOULD ACTUALLY HELP
INFORM AND STRENGTH AND THE
LOCAL CONVERSATIONS FOR
DISTRICTS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
ABOUT HOW THEY WANT TO
PRIORITIZE THE USE OF THEIR
RESOURCES.
SO THE CURRENT TEMPLATE FOR THE
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS
REQUIRES DISTRICTS IF THEY HAVE
A A RED OR AN ORANGISH FOR THE
TWO LOWEST PERFORMANCE LEVELS ON
ANY OF THE INDICATORS IN THE
DASHBOARD.
THE RECORD TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE DOING ABOUT THAT
PERFORMANCE IN ADDITION THERE
ALSO REQUIRED TO ADDRESS ANY
AREA WHERE THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN PERFORMANCE ON
THOSE INDICATORS BETWEEN STUDENT
GROUPS.
SO AT THE CORE OF THIS IS REALLY
FOCUSING ON ADDRESSING
INEQUITIES INCLUDE IN IT
DISPARITIES IN PERFORMANCE
TRYING TO PROMOTE EQUITY AND
THAT LOCAL CONVERSATION.
NOW IS A PART OF LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN TEMPLATE.
DISTRICTS REQUIRED TO ADDRESS
ANY AREA WHERE THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES IN
PERFORMANCE AMONG STUDENT GROUPS.
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WHEN
THE LAW WAS PASSED THESE PIECES
WERE ALWAYS INTENDED TO OPERATE
AS A SYSTEM F ELEMENTS OF A
SINGLE SYSTEM.
THEY WERE ROLLED OUT SORT OF
INDIVIDUALLY BUT NOW WE'RE IN A
PLACE THAT ALL THE PIECES ARE IN
PLACE OF GOING BACK AND UPDATING
AND IMPROVING THOSE. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE MUTUALLY
REINFORCING KEY QUESTION LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY CONTEXT.
IS WERE PUSHING DECISION MAKING
DOWN BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
PEOPLE KNOW THEIR CONTACTS AND
KNOW WHAT WORKED BEST FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT IT'S ALSO HELPING THEM TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
CONVERSATIONS AND IF NECESSARY
THE HARD CONVERSATIONS.
ABOUT HOW TO PRIORITIZE THE
RESOURCES THEY HAVE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS IN CLASSROOMS
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES.
SO WHERE TO PLACE NOW AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IMPLEMENTATION WE WE WE
WE DO ANTICIPATE THAT THERE WILL
BE WE WILL LEARN.
IN THE SYSTEM A SUPPORT WE WILL
LEARN AS DISTRICTS CONTINUE TO
USE THE DASHBOARD.
AND WE WILL PROBABLY CONTINUE TO
ADJUST AND ADAPT TO ENSURE THAT
AT THE STATE LEVEL IN
CONVERSATION WITH LEGISLATORS
AND OTHERS HOW ARE WE RESPONDING
IN ENSURING THE STATE POLICY IS
ALIGNED TO PROMOTING THAT GOAL
THAT WE HAVE.
WHICH IS IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO THAT HAVE AN
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS LET ME.
THIS IS A LITTLE BIT.
TO BE A LITTLE BIT OFF TRACK BUT
I HOPE NOT SINCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE L. CAP.
NO ONE OF MY CONCERNS IS OF IS
LOCAL FUNDING FOR A SCHOOL
COUNSELORS --
PSYCHOLOGISTS IN SOME CASES
NURSES -- IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THE EL CAP
PROCESS TODAY WITHIN THE A
PRIORITIES IN PARTICULAR SCHOOL
CLIMATE.
THAT REQUIRES THE DISTRICTS TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS PARENTS
TEACHERS.
A CLASSIFIED WHATEVER.
ABOUT THE PRESENCE OR LACK OF
PRESENCE.
AND NUMBERS AND LOCATIONS OF
PSYCHOLOGISTS COUNSELORS AND
NURSES.
I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING THAT
REQUIRES IT AND I'M WONDERING IF
I'VE MISSED SOMETHING SO THAT.
THAT.
ESSENTIALLY THE NUMBER PURSUE A
SUPPORT PERSONNEL IN PLATE IS
NOT A METRIC THAT'S REQUIRED TO
BE ADDRESSED AND THAT'S NOT ONE
OF THE TWENTY ONE REQUIRED
METRICS BECAUSE IT DIRECTLY
RELATES I WOULD THINK.
TO SCHOOL CLIMATE AND MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND WELL BEING OF STUDENTS ON
THE KEYON CAMPUSES RIGHT I I
THINK WHAT WHAT I WHAT I CAN
SHARE IS IT'S IT'S NOT THAT YOU
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT.
IN THIS PARTICULAR POSITIONS BUT
IT IS CERTAINLY AS AS YOU AS YOU
NOTED.
CENTER OFF IT IS SOMETHING WHERE.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT CLIMATE HERE
HI CHRONIC ABSENCE RATES IF YOU
HAVE HIGH SUSPENSION RATES IF
YOU HAVE A LOCAL CLIMATE SURVEY
THAT SHOWS THAT A LOT OF
STUDENTS DON'T FEEL THERE'S AN
ADULT THAT CARES ABOUT THEM.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REQUIRED IN A
MEASURES TO BE LOOKING AT THAT
THOSE ARE EXAMPLES OF WHAT'S THE
ACTION THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE TO
TRY TO ADDRESS AND IMPROVE.
PERFORMANCE ON THAT METRIC AND I
CAN ALL CAPS WE ARE SEEING THAT
THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CHOICES.
THAT DISTRICTS ARE MAKING IN
CONSULTATION WITH THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR RESOURCES AS A
WAY TO ADVANCE THE GOAL IS TO
YOU -- IT
YOU KNOW MAKE SOME ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN SUPPORT PERSONNEL
COUNSELORS NURSES IT'S BETTER.
WELL GIVEN THE WHAT I UNDERSTAND
TO BE THE LEVEL OF STRESS.
IN ACADEMIA THESE DAYS --
WHICH I WOULD ASSUME IS PROBABLY
ALWAYS BEEN THERE AND HIGHER
EDUCATION AT LEAST IT WAS WHEN I
WAS A STUDENTS PROBABLY
EXACERBATED --
TOOL --
GREAT EXTENT TODAY.
I UNDERSTAND THAT STRESS.
TODAY.
EXTENDS NOT ONLY.
IN THE NINE THROUGH TWELVE BUT
RIGHT DOWN INTO ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL.
AND JUST MY PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS --
I'M NOT ADVOCATING TO ADD
ANOTHER PRIORITY TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL.
CATEGORY PLANNING PROCESS BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME WITHIN THE EXISTING
ARCHITECTURE AND THE EIGHT
PRIORITIES.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
REQUIRE.
DISTRICTS TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH PARENTS AND TEACHERS.
ABOUT.
THE MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL BEING
OF STUDENTS ON THE CAMPUSES IN
THE AND WHETHER OR NOT
ADDITIONAL.
MENTAL HEALTH AND RELATED.
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE FUNDED OUT
OF THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
MONEY THAT MOVES DOWN THE
PIPELINE.
AND IF IN DOING SO AND IF IN
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUIREMENTS
ARE IDENTIFIED THEN THAT WOULD
INFORM FOLKS.
WHEN THEY COME UP HERE?
AS TO WHATTHEY NEED TO BE
ASKING US.
FOR BECAUSE I THINK THERE'S
PROBABLY NO HIGHER PRIORITY
AMONG MY COLLEAGUES ALTHOUGH I
HAVEN'T TAKEN A WHOLE.
THEN THE THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING.
OF STUDENTS ON OUR CAMPUSES AT
ALL LEVELS.
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT YOU KNOW.
THE L. CAPS SO I'M I'M I'D ASK
YOU MEAN I'M.
IDEAS THAT YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT AND SEE IF WE'VE WE'VE DONE
ENOUGH.
BECAUSE IF IF THE LANGUAGE IS
VAGUE.
THEN IT'S AN AND THE PARENTS ARE.
FOR SOME REASON KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT IT OR AREN'T FORCEFUL
ABOUT IT.
THEN IT SEMS TO ME AS PART OF
THE PLANNING PROCESS WE COULD
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THE
SUBJECT IS NEVER DISCUSSED.
AND THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO ME --
HOPEFULLY IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO
THE FIRST FLOOR.
SO THIS IS MY COMMENT OTHER THAN
THAT I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
CENTER MARONEY QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS.
YOU'VE DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB ALL
OF THE PANELISTS AND ALL OF THE
ALL I THOUGHT HE WAS CLOSING AYE
THANKS SORRY.
YOUR YOUR THE CLOSER.
DAN HAD OUR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
THE MINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THE
INCREASED ROLE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA EDUCATION --
WITH THE BUDGET FLEXIBILITY THAT
THE LOCAL CONTROL OR THAT LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES HAVE UNDER
THE NOW FULLY IMPLEMENTED LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. TO THE
AND THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND
ACCOMPANYING TRAILER BILL.
CONTAINS SEVERAL PROPOSALS TO
HELP STRENGTHEN THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY AND OPEN
PROVE OUTCOMES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
THE FIRST IS THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
FUND. TO SUPPORT THE ALIGNMENT
AND INTEGRATION OF ONLINE
PLATFORM SUPPORTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD.
THE LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY.
PLAN ELECTRONIC TEMPLATE SYSTEM.
AND THE SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT CARDS.
SIMILAR TO PASS PROPOSALS THIS
FUNDING WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
WHO IS THE CONTRACTOR FOR ALL
THREE SYSTEMS?
IN A GREAT INTEGRATING THESE.
SYSTEMS INTO A SINGLE WEB BASED
APPLICATION MY HOPE INCREASING
GAUGE WITH BETWEEN COMMUNITIES
AND EA'S BY ALLOWING THE PUBLIC
ACCESS SINGLE PLATFORM FOR THIS
INFORMATION.
STREAMLINING THE SYSTEMS AND
ELIMINATING DUPLICATIVE AN
OUTDATED INFORMATION.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND. TO MAKE PERMANENT
TO POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
THERE WAS SUPPORT THE ONGOING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD TO MEET STATE
AND FEDERAL ACCOUNTABILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE ADMINISTRATION
RECOGNIZED SIGNIFICANT ROLE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
PLAY WITHIN THE SYSTEM WIDE --
THE STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
IN ORDER TO ALIGN WITH THE
EXPECTED WORKLOAD AND THE
COLLABORATIVE.
AND FOR THE SUPPORT ITS MISSION
OF PROVIDING SUPPORT TO L. EA IS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
INCREASING FUNDING FOR THE CUP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL XCELLENCE.
I TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND.
BRING ITS TOTAL ALLOCATION TO
ELEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TASKING THE
COLLABORATIVE WITH.
THE ROLE OF A SO IT IN THE
COORDINATION OF ACTIVITIES BEING
UNDERTAKEN.
BY THE VARIOUS ENTITIES INVOLVED
IN THE STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES TWENTY
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
SUPPORT A DISTRICTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE. FOR A TOTAL OF
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THIS IS
AN INCREASE FROM SIXTY SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
PROVIDING THE CURRENT YEAR. FOR
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FEDERAL FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS
IDENTIFIED FOR CONFERENCE OF
SUPPORT IMPROVEMENT UNDER THE
EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
IS NOT LIKELY CHANGE DURING THE
SPRING PROCESS. TO REFLECT
UPDATED FEDERAL GRANT
INFORMATION ONLY.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES SEVERAL
TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS INTO
PROVIDING MORE PAIR PARITY --
BETWEEN THE EL CAP DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
SPECIFICALLY THE LANGUAGE
SPECIFIES THE CHARTER SCHOOL
SHOULD BE ADDRESSING STATE
PARTIES TO THE RAIN.
THEY'RE ALL CAPS ADOPTING THEIR
CAPS AT A PUBLIC HEARING.
PROMINENTLY POSTING THEIR CAPS
ON THEIR WEBSITES.
INTRANSITIVE REPORTS IN NOTICES
IF 15% OF OR MORE OF THEIR
STUDENTS ENROLLED SPEAKER
PRIMARY LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH.
THESE CHANGES ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE REQUIREMENTS PLACED ON
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS IT
WILL BRING MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO TURN
OPERATIONS.
WITH THAT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS YEAH.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE FIRST TIME
I'VE SEEN ANYTHING HAVING TO DO
WITH SOFTWARE AND ONLINE
PLATFORM IT'S THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
GOOD FOR YOU IS OUT OF MONEY --
WE BELIEVE THAT SUFFICIENT ONE
TIME MONEY TO COVER THE THE
COMBINATION OF THESE THREE
SYSTEMS ARE THERE ON ONGOING
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WILL BE
ONGOING COSTS HOWEVER THE THE WE
HAVE A FORMAL ESTIMATE FOR WHAT
THOSE ONGOING COSTS WILL BE.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE PROVIDING THE
ONE TIME COST TO HELP ONLINE YOU
SYSTEMS AND AS WE HAVE A BETTER
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THE ON GOING
COSTA RICA FOR THE CONVERSATIONS
TOMORROW.
IT IS A GOOD JOB [inaudible] FOR
I CLOSE UP THANK YOU ALL ANYBODY
ELSE.
EVERYBODY SAID EVERYTHING I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
WAS AN EXCELLENT PANEL I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
NOW LET'S.
TURN IT OVER TO PUBLIC COMMENT
--
ROTH CENTER MORALE AND STAFF
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS.
I YOU'VE COVERED A LOT OF VERY
IN DEPTH AND COMPLICATED ISSUES
TODAY --
JUST LEAVE YOU WITH SOME QUICK
COMMENTS.
A ONE WITH RESPECT TO LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THAT WERE VERY HEARTENED BY THE
FACT THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
MAINTAINING THE COMMITMENT TO
THE LCF APPROACH.
I'M.
QUITE SURE THAT OVER THE COURSE
OF THIS YEAR YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOME PRESSURES.
A TO A TINKER WITH THE LC FF
PERHAPS CREATE CARVE OUTS WITHIN
THE LCF HALF.
OF ALL WELL MEANING EFFORTS --
WE WOULD URGE OR ENCOURAGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO A STAY THE
COURSE THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE HAS JUST
RECENTLY APPROVED.
A AUDIT OF L. CFF AUDIT.
I WILL PERHAPS SET THE STAGE FOR
A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF LCF
HALF.
OF THAT I'M SURE THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN DOING AT
SOME POINT.
WITH REGARD TO THE STATEWIDE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
OF WE CERTAINLY DO A SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL --
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE THAT COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION PLAY IN
THAT SYSTEM --
GREAT CONVERSATION BY THE PANEL
OF THERE'S A LOT OF GREAT WORK
THAT'S BEING DONE.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL A FOR EXAMPLE
JUST YESTERDAY AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY ARE COUNTY OFFICE STAFF
JOINED BY C. C. E..
N. C. D. AHEAD OF WILL DAY LONG
MEETING AS PART OF THIS ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS. TO WORK WITH OUR
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED FOR DIFFERENTIATED
SUPPORT.
A TO REALLY DIG DOWN DEEP.
AND TO DETERMINE WHAT LEVELS OF
SUPPORT DO WE NEEDTO PROVIDE IN
ORDER TO IF THEY'RE NOT SHOWING
ADEQUATE PROGRESS ON THE
DASHBOARD. TO TURN THAT AROUND.
AND THEN LASTLY SENATOR ROTH
WITH RESPECT TO YOUR COMMENT ON
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
IT IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
OF ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY ARE --
IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF THEIR
THINKING A TO GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE.
LAST YEAR SANTA CENTER.
WHEN YOU HAVE A ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE BY A THIRD GRADER THAT
TENDS?
TO MAKE YOU STAND UP AND TAKE
NOTICE WIND UP THERE EL CAP.
AND DAY COMPLETELY RE DID A
SECTION TO DEVELOP --
DISTRICT WIDE STRATEGY AND
STRIKE FORCE IF YOU WILL A TO
REALLY BEGAN.
TO PROVIDE THAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT.
NOW OF COURSE THE QUESTION IS
WHEN YOU DO THAT THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU CAN'T DO --
SO THAT GET TAKES US BACK TO THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING AND NOW WE KNOW
THERE WILL NEVER BE ENOUGH TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE WANT TO DO.
ABOUT WE WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE.
YOU TO A MAINTAIN THAT
COMMITMENT TO PROP NINETY EIGHT
AND TO HELP US.
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO BE MORE
EFFICIENT WITHIN PROP.
NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS SIR YES MA'AM.
FAIR ABOUT JUST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS A COMMANDING
THE MINISTRATION FOR THE
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE LCS
FAST AS WELL AS OUR SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT.
I DO WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT COORDINATION AND AND
SUPPORTING ELLIE ACE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO DIFFERENT STREAMS OF
RESOURCES FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ONE BEING PROPOSITION
THIRTY A SIXTY NINE SIXTY THREE
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT SIX THAT
WOULD.
ON HOW SCHOOLS IN CORD NEED TO
LEVERAGE RESOURCES FOR THESE
NECESSARY SERVICES SO ANY
OPPORTUNITY THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CREATE TO RECOGNIZE IF THERE ARE
OTHER POTS OUTSIDE A PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT CAN'T THAT CAN.
BE INCLUDED FOR EDUCATION THAT
CAN HELP US LEVERAGE COUNTY
RESOURCES SO THERE WERE ALL
WORKING TOGETHER INSTEAD OF
WORKING IN SILOS THAT'S WHAT
SERVICE BASS OUR COMMUNITIES AND
OUR STUDENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM ELISABETH ASK AVAIL --
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
ACTUALLY HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION COALITION WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ON ONGOING ELSE YET THE
FUNDING.
BUT WE I'VE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
MUST CONTINUE TO DO MORE AND
IT'S A STRIVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT DEFINITELY --
WE ARE STILL UNDER FUNDED AND
WANT TO CONTINUE PUSHING FOR
ADDITIONAL ALSO A FUNDING --
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE TWENTY POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND FOR THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
AND THE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
DASHBOARD AND ALIGNING OTHER --
REPORTING TOOLS TOGETHER.
ON THE CHARTER SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY OR SUPPORT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
IMPLEMENT STATEWIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROCESS POLICIES
THAT HOLD SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION ACCOUNTABLE
FOR OPERATIONAL TRANSPARENCY AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
UP ON THE TEST THREE BE CUT
PIECE WE DO HAVE CONCERNS AND
OPPOSE THE PRESIDENT THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY CUTS GENERAL
FUND SUPPORT.
FOR SCHOOLS IN REDUCES PROP
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE
PURSUANT TO THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADOPTED TWO
YEARS AGO.
AND THREE WOULD RE ARE TO THE
REPEAL OF THE TEST THREE DEEP
CUTS.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
CATHERINE OCCURRED ON ON BEHALF
OF COPYING CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER
MY ITEM I MAKE COMMENTS OR
FRIGHTENED.
THREE WE WRITE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU CONSIDER
ALLOCATING FIVE MILLION TO THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WHICH HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED AS THE STATE'S TITLE
THREE LEAD AGENCY FOR ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
AS A LEAD AGENCY THEY PROVIDE
SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE TO
REGIONAL TITLE THREE LEADS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS IS THE ONLY LEAD AGENCY OF
ALL OF THE ENTITIES BUILT INTO
THE STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
SUPPORT THAT DOESN'T HAVE FUNDS
TO CONDUCT THEIR WORK REGIONALLY
OR STATEWIDE.
OTHER COE IT LEADS HAVE RECEIVED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FUNDING.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND REVISING THE
STATE DEFINITION FOR THE ENGLISH
LEARNER ACADEMIC INDICATORS. TO
BE IS AGGRAVATED BY ENGLISH
LEARNER AND RE CLASSIFIED
ENGLISH LEARNERS SEPARATELY AND
EACH BE ALLOWED A COLOR.
SEVERAL ANALYSES HAVE INDICATED
THAT ADVOCATING THE SCORES THE
SCORES WHICH IS THE CURRENT CASE
MASS THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT YELLS AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AND THIS HAS DIMINISH THE NUMBER
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR RECEIVING
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE THANK
YOU.
THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING ANDREA BALL HERE ON
BEHALF OF THREE CLIENT GROUPS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION.
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AN
ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ALMA HAAR'S COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT.
ON THE L. C. F. F. WE ALL
CONTINUED ALLOCATION OF FUNDING
IN THE INCREASE OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND THE COLA
[inaudible]
I'M.
ALSO I WANTED TO POINT OUT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PROP NINETY
EIGHT IT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE
NOT YOU'RE PROBABLY AWARE IN
YOUR AREA IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
BUT IN ALL OF THOSE AREAS I JUST.
CLIENT AREAS WE DO HAVE SOME
DISTRICTS THAT ARE GROWING IN
FACT THE WILD IN ROMAN ACROSS
THE STATE IS DECLINING.
WE HAVE SOME DISTRICTS SPECIALLY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
SUBURBAN DISTRICTS WHETHER IN
CONTINUING TO GROW SO.
JUST BRINGS A DIFFERENT DYNAMIC.
YOUR POINT MISTER CHAIRMAN ON
SHARING BEST PRACTICES IS
SOMETHING ALL OF THEM WANT YOU
REALLY HIT THE POINT HOW CAN
THEY ACCESS AND LEARN FROM EACH
OTHER.
AND AGAIN TO YOUR POINT ON
SUPPORTING STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
THAT'S A SPECIFIC AREA THAT EACH
OF THEM HAVE ASKED FOR
INFORMATION ON WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT FUNDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES I'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH
YOUR AND STAFF AND WITH YOU A
PAPER THAT WE DID ON HOW ELLIE
IS.
CAN BETTER ACCESS FUNDING
THROUGH MEDI CAL FOR EARLY
PREVENTION INTERVENTION
DIAGNOSTIC AND TREATMENT THANK
YOU THANK YOU LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT.
THIS CENTER ROTH US SENATOR OF
MORALE MICHAEL HOLE SIZE ARE
HERE.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY
SEVEN SCHOOLDISTRICTS IN KERN
COUNTY -- WE
SERVE ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN MY COMMENTS
REALLY REFLECT THE CONSENSUS
RECOMMENDATIONS OF ALL OF THOSE
DISTRICTS.
HAVE HANDED OUT TO YOU THEREFORE
DECENT TWO OF THE MORE
INTERESTING TODAY'S HEARING.
SOFT SPEAK TO THOSE AND BE VERY
BRIEF.
THE FIRST IS THE BELIEVE THE
EVIDENCE IN THE COUNTY IS
CONSISTENT WITH STATEWIDE
RESEARCH NOW.
SUCCESSFUL IN THERE FOR THE
PRIORITIZE CELL CFF FUNDING AND
COOL ON THE LC OF PFAFF WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE.
A VERY LIMITED RESOURCE YEAR WE
MAY EVEN BE LOOKING AS THE LA --
POINTED OUT EARLIER AT DECLINING
REVENUE BETWEEN JANUARY AND MAY
SO WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
YOU TO GIVE US ORDER REFER TO
USE THAT TO GIVE OUR PRIORITIES.
RATHER THAN ALL OF THE MENU OF
THINGS WE WANT WHAT ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
SECONDLY BECAUSE THE LCF HAS
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
WE BELIEVE THAT NOT SO MUCH THAT
YOU NEED TO PUT MONEY INTO
EXPANDING THE LCF THIS YEAR BUT
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT AND WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT AB
THIRTY NINE MISTER MERRETT SU
CHI'S BILL.
THAT WOULD SET NEW ASPIRATIONAL
TARGETS WE BELIEVE FOR THE L.
CFF BASED ON ITS SUCCESS --
I'VE HANDED OUT TO YOU IN
ADDITION TO THOSE PRIORITIES A
SUMMARY OF THE THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN OUR
COUNTY.
THAT'S CURRENTLY GENERATED BY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO ARE EITHER
POOR.
ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE FOSTER
YOUTH IT'S ABOUT 72% OF OUR
STUDENT POPULATION WE REALLY
REFLECT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE
STATE.
THIS DATA SHOWS FIVE BASIC WE
WE'VE ANALYZE THE DATA AND THE
SPENDING OF THOSE OF THOSE
DISTRICTS --
THERE'S FIVE BASIC AREAS WHERE
THE DISTRICTS SPEND MOST OF
THEIR MONEY.
THE POINT IS THE WITHIN THOSE
FIVE AREAS THEY'RE VERY DIVERSE
AND VERY DIFFERENT IN WHAT THEY
TARGET.
THERE EL CAPS ARE DRIVEN IS
MISTER SAP POINTED OUT TO YOU BY
THE STATEWIDE PRIORITIES AND THE
NEED TO TARGET OUR HIGH NEED
STUDENTS AND THEY'RE DOING THAT.
AND WE HAVE SUCCESS ON THAT
WHICH TODAY'S HEARING DOESN'T
HAVE TIME FOR ME TO GET INTO BUT
MY POINT IS IS THEY'RE DOING IT
IN VERY DIFFERENT WAYS --
THEY'RE SPENDING THEIR TARGETING
ONE EXAMPLE THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS THE LARGEST HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE.
THERE SPENDING ALMOST 15% OF
THEIR SUPPLEMENTAL IN
CONCENTRATION MONEY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS.
ON CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
BECAUSE THEIR COMMUNITY AND
THEIR ANALYSIS OF THEIR STUDENTS.
IS THAT INVESTING IN CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION IS THE BEST
WAY TO DECREASE --
EXPULSION RATES INCREASE
GRADUATION RATES IMPROVE
ACHIEVEMENT ON THE PART OF THEIR
TARGETED STUDENT POPULATION.
THAT'S NOT TRUE OF ALL UNIFIED
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE OR EVEN
ALL DISTRICTS IN OUR COUNTY.
BUT THEY HAVE THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DO THAT WITHIN THE L. CFF BEING
DRIVEN BY STATE WHY PRIORITIES
THAT MR SAP --
REFERENCE TO YOU SO WE THINK THE
LCF IS A SUCCESS STORY AND WE WE
HOPE YOU'LL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN NOW ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THE PRIOR SPEAKER IN RELATION TO
INCREASING IN MAKING INVESTMENTS
IN LCF --
FIVE WE WOULD CERTAINLY AGREE
WITH THAT IS AND WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF MR MYERS TO CHEESE
SB THIRTY NINE PROPOSAL --
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE DIRECTION OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDING THE CREATION OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
CONCENTRATION GRANT --
I KNOW IT WAS IN A TOPIC IN
TODAY'S HEARING BUT IT'S AS FAR
AS SPECIAL EDUCATION WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE LOOKING AT IT.
OFF FROM THE LAND AS WHETHER THE
FUNDING IS TARGETED IT'S A NEED
BASED.
I AND IS THERE A CORRELATION TO
STUDENT I IN TERMS OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
AND FINALLY --
SINCE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT --
EIGHTY EIGHTY FUNDING SYSTEM
CAME OUT VERSUS AN ENROLLMENT I
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT --
LAUSD CERTAINLY WELCOMES HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION AND AND
LOOKING AT THAT --
SYSTEM AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS
THANK YOU.
YOU.
ARE WE DONE.
A JOHN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION --
I'D SAY PROBABLY ON LC FF AND
PROP NINETY EIGHT WE SUPPORT --
FULLY FUNDING ALL SCHOOLS --
ON ISSUE THREE WITH THE EL CAP.
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY PIECES AS IT
APPLIES TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
ON LINING THE STATEWIDE GOALS TO
THROUGH EIGHT TO ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE HAVE SOME MISSION
DRIVEN.
SMALL CHARTERS WERE THAT
WOULDN'T REALLY FIT AND SO WE
WOULD --
WE'RE ASKING FOR THAT TO BE
REMOVED THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
[inaudible]
I HAD.
THING NO THE PUBLIC COMMON
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENDANCE IT
WAS A FINE DISCUSSION LOOK
FORWARD TO NEXT WEEK'S.
WE ARE ADJOURNED [inaudible]
IF YOU